aure Microsoft's cloud computing
platform is a captivating world of
innovation and possibilities what makes
Azure truly fascinating is its constant
Evolution as new features and
capabilities are regularly added
enabling businesses to scale innovate
and transform their operations so
welcome to our Azure Cloud course in
this course we will explore the
fundamental aspects of aor exploring
what aor is our journey includes
comprehensive Azure training making sure
you grasp the essential Azure machine
learning tutorial is a highlight as we
break down the concepts in a simple
understandable manner we will delve into
Azure data Factory uncovering its role
in managing data efficiently we'll also
cover its certification path and Azure
interview questions and answers so let's
embark on this Azure adventure and
unlock the potential of cloud computing
together so if you are interested in
becoming an Azure certified professional
then consider simply learns Azure Cloud
architect Masters program Azure Cloud
architect Masters program will help you
master the Azure infrastructure by
understanding Azure Cloud architect
Technology Solutions implementing
workloads and Security in Azure creating
and deploying apps in aure and securing
data in Azure now who should take this
program fresher graduates who are intent
on taking the plunge into the job market
second professionals with less than 2
years of experience who are working in
either technical or non-technical job
roles and want to shift to the cloud so
what are you waiting for androll now get
certified and get ahead SRA is a country
singer and recently she got sponsored by
North American Music company for her new
album she was really nervous and excited
about the performance once all songs
were recorded she was set to release the
album worldwide so when she inquired
about when it would happen she realized
realized she barely had one week left
she panicked and ran to the manager of
that Music Company Mark to inquire how
everything like editing mixing
portfolios and promotions would be done
in just one week that's when Mark
answered don't you worry our production
is managed on Microsoft Azure Cyra was
confused and asked but isn't Azure a
cloud service used to store your data
Mark smiled and answered well it's true
but Azure is not just that but much more
let me explain it to you mark further
explained that Microsoft Azure is an
open and flexible Cloud platform for
services such as analytics virtual
Computing storage networking and more it
offers a constantly growing selection of
products and services designed to
satisfy all of your demands on a single
practical platform it enables its users
to engage in cloud computing and is
designed to manage tasks through
Microsoft's data centers a data center
is a structure with networked computers
storage systems and and computational
infrastructure that organizations like
us use to gather process store and
distribute massive amounts of
data upon learning what Azure is used
for she was still unsure how it would
help her in the album release Mark
explained that in Azure every production
happens simultaneously every day Azure
builds Mission critical solutions to
analyze images comprehend speech and
make predictions using data
simultaneously hence multitasking
he further added that all the data of
her album for example footage and audio
travel securely to the cloud from even
the most remote locations all the data
is securely stored in the cloud which
can easily be accessed by the editors
and other production members immediately
on realizing every process would run in
parallel Cyra was under the impression
that all this would be a tedious and
timec consuming job then Mark answered
no only the data relevant to their role
would be accessible to them same
platform same tools same workflow but
just more efficient and secure Cyrus
started wondering ask that it must cost
them a fortune to use such advanced
technology Mark further explained that
the costs are easily controllable so we
only pay for what we use and because our
album is stored in the cloud it's
accessible from every corner of the
world for example producers can review
approve and make changes in real time
and video indexing makes the album
searchable and understandable predictive
analytics makes the most of marketing
and distribution strategies therefore no
ad dollars are wasted or seats are left
empty secure distribution means album
releases smoothly and on time as soon as
the audience starts watching and
reacting to every interaction Azure
analyzes their viewing habits to drive
recommendations advertising and
personalization this makes future
production decisions really easy Zara
was relieved to understand this new
technology and and how it would help her
build her future career Azure is the
best public cloud service available
today thanks to its speed flexibility
and affordability as well as its
features and pricing the Azure platform
intends to assist organizations in
managing difficulties and achieving
their objectives it provides solutions
that work with open-source Technologies
and supports all Industries including
e-commerce finance and several Fortune
organizations so here's a question for
you
Azure provides which type of cloud
computing service one infrastructure as
a service two platform as a service
three software as a service four all of
the above give the correct answer in
reasoning and stand a chance to win an
Amazon voucher think about it and leave
your answers in the comments section and
we will provide the answer next week
today some of the biggest companies in
the world like eBay Boeing Samsung and B
BMW are now using the Microsoft Azure
infrastructure and the support they
require for their better production and
performance when it comes to cloud
service providers Microsoft azure's
adaptability is proving to be a valuable
quality that makes it a good choice in
the healthcare manufacturing consumer
Appliance travel Aviation and
entertainment sectors hi guys this is
Rob from Simply learn and today we'll be
talking about one of the fastest growing
and second largest cloud computing
platform form in the market right now
I'm talking about Microsoft as your now
before we begin let's talk about what
we'll be covering in this video first
we'll talk about why you should be
interested in cloud computing what
exactly is cloud computing what is
Microsoft as your some of its services
and the users of AO now let's start with
why you should be interested in cloud
computing now let's say you have an idea
for a revolutionary application an idea
that taks both the boxes when it comes
to good applications one it has great
user experience and two it'll be highly
profitable now for it to be successful
you'll have to release it on the
internet people need to use it they need
to spread the word and then it'll become
truly famous however for that you're
going to need servers storage developers
a dedicated Network and application
security to ensure your application
works the way it does now these are a
lot of components and that's where the
problem lies there are two major
disadvantages to this approach the
initial setup is very expensive risky
which means this requires a huge amount
of capital upfront to ensure that it
works properly and the downside is if
your application does not become famous
or it doesn't return as much as you
expect it to you're probably not going
to get the money back which means it
provides a huge amount of risk and then
on the flip side if it does become
famous your number of users have
increased which means that you'll have
to buy more servers and storage systems
to keep up with your demand and this
problem can be solved with the help of
cloud computing now that you to know why
you should be interested in cloud
computing let's go into the details of
what exactly is cloud computing now
cloud computing is basically a platform
that gives you access to a number of
computing resources and this is possible
with the help of the internet now as a
user all you need to do is go to a cloud
service provider through your laptop or
your computer through the internet of
course connect to that cloud service
provider and then there you go you have
access to Computing resources now
Computing resources may include you know
serverless Computing virtual machines
storage and so much more now let's dig a
Little Deeper now basically these cloud
service providers actually have massive
data centers now in these data centers
what you have are hundreds of servers
also included our storage systems and
mainly several organizations critical
components so these are very secure safe
locations where a large amount of data
is stored hence the name data centers
now it is to these data centers that
users actually connect to collect their
data or use it so actually users can
access any service based on their
requirement now like I told you there's
a number of services the user can use
for example now if you want a
notification every time someone sends
you a message or perhaps once you get an
email you need a copy of it created now
for all of this there are services and
most importantly almost every cloud
service provider has this option where
users only pay for the service that they
use so there's no charge UPF front where
tell you that you need to pay x amount
of money so that you can use our
services you're only paying for the
amount of time that you're using these
Services now cloud computing is used for
a wide variety of reasons firstly
there's machine learning and data
analysis now basically there are
services that analyze your data and tell
you how you can work with this data
better then there's data storage and
backup streaming media content for
example did you know that the shows that
you watch on Netflix actually all of
them are in the cloud so you're
connected to the internet and and you
browse through Netflix and you get
access to the videos these are possible
with the help of cloud service providers
there's creating and testing
applications automating software
delivery which is a component in devops
and hosting blogs and applications so
now what is azure what's the big cloud
service provider all about so Azure is a
cloud computing platform provided by
Microsoft now it's basically an online
portal through which you can access and
manage resources and services now
resources and services are nothing but
you know you can store your data and you
can transform the data using services
that Microsoft provides again all you
need is the internet and being able to
connect to the Azo portal then you get
access to all of the resources and their
services in case you want to know more
about how it's different from its rival
which is AWS I suggest you click on the
top right corner and watch the AWS
versus a video so that you can clearly
tell how both these cloud service
providers are different from each other
now here are some things that you need
to know about a year it was launched in
February 1st 2010 which is significantly
later than when AWS was launched it's
free to start and has a pay per use
model which means like I said before you
need to pay for the services you use
through aor and one of the most
important selling points is that 80% of
Fortune 500 companies use Azure Services
which means that most of the bigger
companies of the world actually
recommend using AZ and then Azia
supports a wide variety of programming
languages the C sh nodejs Java and so
much more another very important selling
point of aure is the amount of data
centers it has across the world now it's
important for a cloud service provider
to have many data centers around the
world because it means that they can
provide their services to a wider
audience now Azor has 42 which is more
than any cloud service provider has at
the moment it expects to have 12 more in
a period of time which brings its total
number of regions it covers to 54 now
let's talk talk about Azo Services now
Azo Services have 18 categories and more
than 200 services so we clearly can't go
through all of them it has services that
cover compute a machine learning
integration management tools identity
devops web and so much more you're going
to have a hard time trying to find a
domain that Azure doesn't cover and if
it doesn't cover it now you can be
certain they're working on it as we
speak so first let's start with the
compute Services first virtual machine
with this service what you're getting to
do is to create a virtual machine of
Linux or Windows operating system it's
easily configurable you can add RAM you
can decrease RAM you can add storage
remove it all of it is possible in a
matter of seconds now let's talk about
the second service cloud service now
with this you can create a application
within the cloud and all of the work
after you deploy it deploying the
application that is is taken care of by
aard which includes you know
provisioning the applic application load
balancing ensuring that the application
is in good health and all of the other
things are handled by aor next up let's
talk about service fabric now with
service fabric the process of developing
a micros service is greatly simplified
so you might be wondering what exactly
is a microservice now a microservice is
basically an application that consists
of smaller applications coupled together
next up functions now with functions you
can create applications in any
programming language that you want want
another very important part is that you
don't have to worry about any hardware
components you don't have to worry what
Ram you require or how much storage you
require all of that is taken care of by
Azure all you need is to provide the
code to Azure and it'll execute it and
you don't have to worry about anything
else now let's talk about some
networking Services first up we have
Azure CDN or the content delivery
Network now the azos CDN service is
basically for delivering web content to
users now now this content is of high
bandwidth and can be transferred or can
be delivered to any person across the
world now these are actually a network
of servers that are placed in strategic
positions across the world so that the
customers can obtain this data as fast
as possible next up we have Express rout
now with this you can actually connect
your on promise Network onto the
Microsoft cloud or any of the services
that you want through a private
connection so the only communication
that happens is between your on promiz
Network and the service that you want
then you have virtual Network now with
virtual Network you can have any of the
Azure Services communicate with each
other in a secure manner in a private
manner next we have azard DNS so azur
DNS is a hosting service which allows
you to host their DNS or domain name
system domains in Azure so you can host
your application using Azure DNS now for
the storage Services first up we have
dis storage with dis storage you're
given a costeffective option of choosing
HDD or solid state drives to go along
with your virtual machines based on your
requirements then you have blob storage
now this is actually optimized to ensure
that they can store massive amounts of
unstructured data which can include Text
data or even binary data next you have
file storage which is a managed file
storage and can be accessible via the
SMB protocol or the server message block
protocol and finally you have q storage
now with Q storage you can provide
durable message queuing for an extremely
large workload and the most important
part is that this can be accessed from
anywhere in the world now let's talk
about how a your can be used firstly for
application development it could be any
application mostly web applications then
you can test the application see how
well it works you can host the
application on the internet you can
create virtual machines like I mentioned
before with the service you can create
these virtual Machines of any size or
Ram that you want you can integrate and
Sync features you can collect and store
metrices for example how the data Works
how the current data is how you can
improve upon it all of that is possible
with these services and you have virtual
hard drives which is an extension of the
virtual machines where these services
are able to provide you a large amount
of storage where data can be stored
Azure tutorial I'm Sam and Azure Cloud
architect working for simply learn and
I'm more than glad to walk you through
this session where we're going to talk
about Azure in great length and breadth
and if you looking for a video that
talks and walks you through all the
services in Azure then this could be one
of the best video you could find in the
internet and without any further delay
let's get started everybody likes
stories it so let's get started with a
story in a city not so far away a CEO
had plans to expand his company globally
and called one of his IT personnel for
an IT opinion and this guy has been in
the company for a long time and is very
seasoned with the company's infra and he
nicely answered the questions with what
he foresaw and he said I have a good
news and a bad news for us to go Global
and he starts with the good news he said
sir we're well on our way to become one
of the world's largest shipping company
and the bad news is however our data
centers have almost run out of space and
setting up new ones around the world
would be too expensive and very time
consuming now the IT personnel let's
call him Mike now he explains the
situation from how he saw it but the CEO
had done some homework about how he was
going to do it and he answered Mike
saying don't worry about that mic I've
come up with a solution for a problem
and it's called Microsoft Azure well
Mike is an hardworking and harnessed IT
professional working for that company
but he did not spend time on learning
the latest Technologies and he asked
this question very honestly oh how does
it solve a problem and the CEO begins to
explain Azure to Mike and he starts with
what is cloud computing and then he goes
on and talks about Azure and the service
is offered by Azure and why Azure is
better than the other Cloud providers
and what are the great companies that
uses Azure and how they got benefited
out of it and then he winds it all up
with the use cases of azure so he begins
his explanation saying Microsoft Azure
is known as the cloud service provider
and it works on the basis of cloud
computing now Microsoft Azure is
formerly known as Windows Azure and it's
a Microsoft's public cloud computing
platform it also provides a range of
cloud services including some of them
are compute analytics storage and
networking we can always pick and choose
from these services to develop and scale
our applications or even plan on running
existing applications in the public
Cloud Microsoft Azure is both a platform
as a service and infrastructure as a
service let's now fit their conversation
out and let's talk about what is cloud
computing aure services offered by Azure
how is azure leading when compared to
other cloud service providers and what
are the companies that are using Azure
let's talk about that in simple terms
cloud computing is being able to access
compute services like servers storage
database networking software analytics
intelligence and a lot more over the
Internet which is the cloud with the uh
flexibility of the resources that we use
like anytime I wanted resource I can use
one and it becomes available in
immediately and anytime if I want to
retire and resource I can simply retire
a resource and not pay for it and we
also typically pay only for the services
that we use and this helps greatly with
our operating cost to run our
infrastructure more efficiently and
scale our environment up or down
depending on the business needs and
changes and all the servers and storages
and databases and networking all that
that are accessed through the network of
remote systems or remote computers
hosted in the internet typically in the
provider's data center which is azure in
this case now we don't use any physical
server or an on premises server here
well we still use physical servers and
VMS in a hosted on a hardware or a
physical server but they're all in the
providers en environment and none of
them sit on premises or in our data
center we only access them remotely it
looks and feels the same except for the
fact that they are in a remote location
we access them remotely do all the work
remotely and when we're done we can shut
it down and not pay for them so some of
the use cases some of the use cases of
cloud computing are creating
applications and services the other use
cases are store storing or using Cloud
for storage alone if there is one thing
that ever grows in an organization is
the storage every new day there is a new
storage requirement and it's very
Dynamic it's very hard to predict and if
we go out and buy a big storage capacity
up front and until we use the storage
capacity fully the empty storages you
know we're wasting money on them so
instead I can go for a storage which
scales that dynamically that's in the
cloud put storage or put data in the
cloud and pay only for what you're
storing and for the next month if you
have deleted or flushed out some files
or data pay less for it so it's a very
Dynamic storage in the cloud and a lot
of companies are getting benefited from
storing data in the cloud because of its
uh dynamic in nature and the cost that
comes along with it the cheap cost that
comes along with it and also they give a
lot of the providers like Azure they
give a data application for free they
promise an SLA along with the data we
store in the cloud so there's an SL
attached to it and they also provide
data recoveries as well if in case
something goes wrong with the physical
disk where our data is stored Azure
automatically makes our data available
from the Redundant or other places where
it had stored our data because of the
SLA they wanted to keep the other use
case for Azure is hosting websites and
running blogs using the compute service
be it storing music and letting your
users stream the music aure is a good
place to store music and stream the
music with the benefit of CDN content
delivery Network which allows us to
stream a video or audio files with great
speed you know with that with Azure our
audio or video application works
seamlessly because they are provided to
the client with very low latency and
that improves the customer experience
for our application Azure compute
service is a good place for delivering
software on demand there are a lot of
softwares embed softwares that we can
buy using Azure and everything on aay
asigo service model so anytime we need a
software we can go out and immediately
buy the software for the next 1 hour or
two hour let's say and use them and then
return it back we not bound to any
yearly licensing cost by that Azure
Computing Services has analytic
available for us with which we can
analyze get a good visualization of
what's going on in a network be it logs
be the performance be the metrics you
know instead of looking at logs and
searching logs and trying to do manual
things over the heaps and heaps of logs
that we have saved Azure analytics
Services helps us to get a good visual
of what's going on in the network where
have we dropped where have we increased
or what's causing what's the major
driver what is the top 10 errors that we
get in the server in the application
stuff like that those can can be easily
gathered from the Azure analytic
Services now cloud is really a very cool
term for the internet a good analogy
would be looking back anytime we look at
a diagram when we do not know how things
are transferred we simply draw a cloud
right for example a mail gets sent from
a person in one country to a person in
the other country there a lot of things
happening in between from the time you
hit the send Buton button and the time
the other person hits the read button
right and we the simple and the easiest
way of putting it in a picture is simply
draw a cloud and on the one end one
person will be sending the email and on
the other end the other person will be
reading the email so uh cloud is a
really cool term for the internet now
that's some Basics about cloud computing
now that we've understood about cloud
computing in general let's talk about
Microsoft Azure as a cloud service now
Microsoft Azure is a set of cloud
services to build manage and deploy
applications on a network with the help
of Microsoft azures Frameworks now
Microsoft Azure is a Computing service
created by Microsoft basically for
building testing deploying and managing
applications and services through a
Global Network of Microsoft managed data
centers now now Microsoft Azure provides
SAS which is software as a service and
PAs which is platform as a service and
IAS infrastructure as a service and they
support many different programming
languages tools and framework and those
tools and framework include both
Microsoft specific and third-party
software now let me pick and talk about
a specific service for example
management Azure automation provides a
way for us to automate the manual long
running and frequently repeated tasks
that are commonly performed tasks both
in cloud and Enterprise environment it
saves a lot of time and increases the
reliability and it kind of gives a good
administrative control and even
schedules the task automatically to be
performed on a regular basis to give you
a quick history of Microsoft Azure it
was launched on 1st February
2010 and it was awarded or it was called
an industry leader for infrastructure
and platform as service by Gartner now
Gartner is the world's leading research
and advisory company this Microsoft
Azure supports a number of programming
languages like C Java and python all
these School Services we get to use and
pay only for how much we use for example
if we use for an R we only get to pay
for an hour even the costliest system
available if you use them for an hour we
only pay for that particular hour and
then we're done no more billing on the
resource that we have used Microsoft
Azure has spread itself more than 50
regions around the world so it's quite
easy for us to pick a region and you
know start provisioning and running our
applications probably from day one
because the infr structure and the tools
and Technologies needed to run our
application are already available all
that we have to do is come at the code
in that particular region or build an
application and launch it in that
particular region and they become live
starting day one now because we have 50
regions around the world we can very
carefully design our environment to
provide low latency services to our
customers all right instead of In
traditional data center let's say
you know customers will have to or their
request will have to travel all the way
around the globe to reach a data center
which lives in the other side of the
planet and this adds more latency to it
and it is really not feasible to build a
data center uh near each customer
location because of the cost involved
but with Azure it's possible Azure
already has data centers around the
world and all that we have to do is just
pick a data center build an environment
there they're available starting day one
number one and also the cost is
considerably saved because we are using
a public Cloud instead of an physical
infrastructure to serve those customers
from a very local location and these
services that Azure is offering is ever
increasing as of now as we speak we have
like 200 plus services offered and they
span through different domain or
different platforms or different
Technologies available within the Azure
console portal now we're going to talk
about that later in this section so hold
your breath till we talk about it but
for now just know that we have like 200
plus services offered by Azure let's now
talk about different services and Azure
starting with artificial intelligence
plus machine learning where we have a
lot of tools and
Technologies so the wide variety of
services available in Azure includes
artificial intelligence plus machine
learning plus analytic services to get
an or to give us a good visual of how
the data or how the application is
performing or the type of the category
of data stored and to read from the logs
and variety of compute Services
different VMS with different size and
different operating systems different
containers available different type of
databases available a lot of developer
tools that are available for us and
identity service to manage our users in
the Azure cloud and those users can be
integrated or Federated with let's say
Google Facebook you know LinkedIn so
they are some external Federation
Services they can be used to integrate
with our identity system iots iot
Services iot tools and Technologies
available and management tools to manage
the users you know creating identity is
one and then managing them on top of it
is a totally different thing and we have
tools Technologies to manage the uh
users cool services for data migration
data migration is now made simple tools
and Technologies available for mobile
application uh development and I can
plan my own network in the cloud with
the networking Services I can Implement
my own security both Azure provider and
third party Security Services on Azure
Cloud that's now possible and lot of
storage options available in the cloud
so these are just a glimpse of the big
list of services available in Azure
Cloud so that was a glimpse of what's
available in the cloud let's talk about
the services in specific let's take
compute for example you know whenever
we're building a new application or
deploying existing ones the azzure
compute service provides the
infrastructure we need to run and
maintain our application we can easily
tap in the capacity that Azure cloud
service has and we can scale our compute
requirement on demand we can also
containerize our application we have the
option of choosing windows or Linux wi
machine and take the advantage of the
flexible options Azure provides for us
to migrate our VMS to Azure and lot more
and these compute Services also include
a full-fledged identity solution meaning
integration with active directory in the
cloud or an on premises and lot more
let's look at some of the services that
this compute domain provides some of the
services the computer domain provides
are virtual machines and this azure
virtual machines gives us the ability to
develop and manage a virtual computer
environment or a virtualized environment
inside azures Cloud environment that to
in a virtual private Network now we will
talk about virtual private Network at a
later point but as of now just know that
there are a lot of services available in
Azure compute service that we can get
benefited from we can always choose from
a very wide range of computer options
for example you know we have an option
to choose the operating system we have
the option to choose whether the system
should be in on premises or in the cloud
or do we want to maintain the
environment both in on premises and in
the cloud we have the option of choosing
the operating system whether we want to
use our own operating system with some
software attached uh to it or do we want
to go and buy the operating system from
the cloud from Azure Marketplace and
these are just a few of the options
available for us when we want to buy the
compute environment and these computer
environments are easily scalable meaning
we can easily scale our VM instances
from one instance to thousands of
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
or simply put in a couple of button
clicks and all these services are
available on a pay for what we use model
model meaning there is no upfront cost
we use the service and then pay for the
services that we have used there's no
literal long-term commitment when it
comes to using virtual machines in the
cloud and these most of the services are
built on a payper minute billing basis
all right and at no point because of the
payper minute billing model at no point
we will be overpaying for any of the
service
that's that's attractive isn't it now
let's talk about batch service now batch
service is always independent regardless
of whether you choose windows or Linux
it's going to run fairly well and with
bat servers we can take advantage of the
environment's unique features and not
only that in short the batch service
helps us to manage the whole batch
environment and also it helps to
schedule the jobs now this Azure batch
service is actually runs on on a large
scale parallel and high performance
Computing because of that batch jobs are
highly efficient in Azure and when we
run bat services this Azure batch
creates a pool of computer nodes and uh
installs the needed applications that we
want to run and then it schedules jobs
to those individual nodes in those pools
as a customer there is no need for us to
install a cluster or there is no need
for us to install a software that
actually schedules the jobs or even to
manage or even to scale those
infrastructure or the software because
everything is managed by Azure and this
batch service is a platform as a service
there is no additional charge for using
this batch service except for I mean the
only charges that we'll be paying is for
the virtual machines that the service
uses and uh the storage that we will be
using of course and uh the networking
services that we will be using for this
batch service let's summarize This Bat
service we have a choice of operating
system that we can pick and use and it
scales by itself now the alternative for
the batch would be cues but in cues
we'll have to pre-provision and pay for
the infrastructure even if we're not
using it but with a batch we only pay
for what we use and this batch service
helps us to manage uh the application
manage the scheduling as a whole as if
they are just one thing as next thing in
compute domain let's talk about this
fabric service now this fabric service
is actually a distributed system
platform that helps us to package deploy
and manage a scalable and a very
reliable microservice and containers and
what does it help this Azure fabric
service helps us or it helps the
developers and administrators so they
can avoid the complex infrastructure
problems and they can focus Fus only on
implementing workloads or taking care of
their development taking care of their
application instead of spending time on
infrastructure so what's service fabric
service fabric it provides runtime
capabilities and uh life cycle
management two applications that are
composed of microservices no
infrastructure management at all and
with service fabric we can easily scale
the application to tens or hundreds or
even to thousands of Machin machines
here machines represent containers as
next thing in compute domain let's talk
about virtual machine scale set now this
virtual machine scale set it lets us to
create a group of identical load
balanced VMS I just want to mention it
again it helps us to manage a group
identical and load balanced VMS the
number of instances or the number of VM
instances in an in a scale set can
increase or decrease in response to uh
the demand or in response to schedule
that we Define you know the resources
needed on a Monday morning is not the
same as that would be required on a
Saturday or a Sunday morning all right
and even within the day the resources
that would be needed in the beginning of
the business hour is not the resources
that would be needed at noon or you know
after 8: or 9 in the evening so the
demands could actually vary in the
environment and the skill set helps us
to take care of the weing demand or take
care of the uh different infrastructure
requirement at a different schedule
throughout the day throughout the week
throughout the month or could be
throughout the year as well the scal set
also allows us to provide High
availability to our applications and it
helps us to uh centrally manage
configure and update a large number of
VMS as if they they are just one thing
now you might ask well virtual machines
are enough why would we need a virtual
machine skill set just like I said this
virtual machine skill that helps us with
a greater redundancy and improved
performance for our applications and
those applications can be accessed
through a load balancer that actually
distributes uh the requests to the
application instances so in a nutshell
this virtual machine scale Set uh it
helps us to create a large number of
identical virtual machines number one
and with scale set we can increase or
decrease the virtual machines with
virtual machine scale set we can
centrally manage and configure and
update a group of VMS and it's a great
use case when it comes to Big Data or
container workloads as next thing in
compute domain uh let's talk about cloud
services now this Azure cloud service is
actually a platform as a service and
it's very friendly in fact it is
designed for applications that support
scalability or an application that
requires scalability or reliability and
and on top of it you want them to be
very inexpensive to operate so asure
cloud service provides all these so
where would this cloud service run well
it runs on a VM but it's a platform as a
service VMS are infrastructure as a
service and when we run applications on
VM through cloud service it becomes
platform as a service so here is how you
got to be thinking with infrastructure
as a service like VMS we first create
and configure the environment and then
we run applications on top of it let's
look at the responsibility the
responsibility for us in VM is that we
manage everything end to end like uh you
know deploying new patches picking the
versions of the operating system and
making sure they are uh intact and all
that stuff it's all managed by us but on
the contrary with platform as a service
it's I mean it's as if the environment
is already ready all that you have to do
is deploy your application in it and
manage the platform I mean manage the
platform not as an administrator because
all the administration is taken care by
Azure like know deploying new versions
of the Opera in system it's all handled
by the Azure so we deploy the
application and we manage the
application that's it infrastructure
management is handled by Azure so what
does cloud service provide this cloud
service provides a platform uh where we
can uh uh write uh the uh application
code and we don't have to worry about
Hardware simply hand over the code and
cloud service takes care of it so no
worry on the hardware at all so
responsibilities like patching what do
we do with something something uh
crashes how do I update the
infrastructure how do I manage uh the
maintenance or the downtime in the
underlying infrastructure all that is
handled by Azure it also provides an
good testing environment for us you know
we can simply run the code test it
before it's actually released to the
production I want to expand a bit on
this testing applications so this Azure
cloud service it actually gives us an
staging environment for testing a new
release without it affecting the
existing release which actually reduces
the customer downtime so we can run the
application test it and anytime that's
ready for production all that's needed
for us to do to move it to production is
simply to swap the staging environment
into the production environment and the
old production environment will now
become the new staging environment where
we can uh add more to it and then swap
it back at a later point so it it kind
of gives us an swappable environment for
testing our applications and not only
that it gives us Health monitoring
alerts it helps us to monitor the health
and availability of our application
there is a dashboard we can benefit from
uh when we use Azure cloud services and
that shows the key statistics all in one
place and we can also set up realtime
alerts to one when a service
availability or a certain metrics that
we are concerned about degrades as next
thing in compute domain let's talk about
functions now functions are serverless
Computing now many time if you heard
about aure being serverless a lot of
time they are referencing or the person
who's talking to you is referencing to
serverless uh Computing or Azure
functions which is a serverless
Computing service hosted on Microsoft
Azure the main motive of uh a function
is to accelerate and simplify
application development functions helps
us to run code on demand without we need
to pre-provision or manage any Azure
infrastructure so Azure functions are
script or a piece of code that gets run
in response to an event that you want to
handle so in short we can just write a
code that you need for a problem at hand
without actually worrying about the
whole application or the infrastructure
that will be running uh that code and
the best of all the best is when we use
functions we only pay for the time that
our code runs so what does functions
provide or what does Azure functions
provide Azure functions allow users to
build applications using serverless uh
simple functions with the programming
language of our choice so the current
programming languages that are supported
is c f nodejs Java and PHP so here we
really don't have to worry about
provisioning or uh maintaining servers
if a code requires more resource yes
Azure functions have handles or it
provides the additional resources needed
by the court and the best part is we
only pay for the amount of time the
functions are running not the resources
but the amount of time the function is
running as next thing and moving to the
new domain let's talk about the
container domain in Azure now the
container domain or the container
service it allows us to quickly deploy a
production ready kubernetes or a Docker
swamp cluster now what's a container a
container is a standard unit of software
that packages of code and all its
dependencies so the applications run
quickly and reliably from one Computing
environment to another it could be
testing uh to staging to developing
development environment to staging to
production or from one production to
another production or on premises uh to
cloud or one Cloud to another Cloud vice
versa now imagine we had an option not
to worry about the VM and just focus on
the application well that's exactly what
containers helps us achieve so these
container instances enable us to focus
on applications and not worrying about
managing VMS or not worrying about the
learning the new tools required to
manage the VMS or even the deployment
and our applications that we create they
run in a container and running in a
container is what helps us to achieve
all these not being able to manage or
not needing to manage the virtual
machines so these containers uh they can
be deployed into the cloud using a
single command if you using command line
interface and a couple of button clicks
if we are using the Azure portal and
these containers are kept lightweight
but they are equally secure as virtual
machines let's talk about container
servic as next thing uh the container
service or U sometimes called as Azure
kubernetes service it helps us to manage
the containers container is one thing
and a service that's used to manage the
container is another thing now this
kubernetes service or ACS it helps us to
manage the containers so let's expand on
this a bit so this Azure container
service or ACS it it actually provides a
way uh to simplify the creation
configuration and management of a
cluster of virtual machines that are
preconfigured to run containerized
applications on top of them and
deploying them deploying these
containers might take like 15 to 20
minutes or deploying the virtual
machines that run containers in it might
take 15 to 20 minutes and once they are
provision we can actually manage them by
using simple SSH tunnel into them and
this ACS when it runs application it
runs applications from Docker images
what does that mean a Docker images
makes sure that the applications the
container runs are fully portable images
are port able and ACS also helps us to
orchestrate the container environment
not only that it also helps us to ensure
that these applications that we run in
containers can be scaled to thousands or
even tens of thousands of containers so
in a nutshell managing an existing
application into a container and running
it using AKs or ACS is really easy or
that's what it is all about to make the
application management or migration easy
now managing the container based
architecture and we discussed that
containers could be tens or even tens of
thousands of containers so managing them
is Made Simple using this container
services and even training of model
using a large data set in a complex and
resource intensive uh environment this
AKs helps us to simplify that uh
environment all right as next thing in
container domain let's talk about
container registry we spoke about
registry a little little bit when we
spoke about Docker images so container
registry is a single place where we can
store our images which are Docker images
when we use when we use containers it's
it's Docker images that we use for our
image purposes so these container images
are a central registry that can be used
to ease container development by easing
the storage and management of container
images so there we can store all kind of
images like U Docker swarm or the images
used in Docker swarm are in kubernetes
everything can be stored in container
registry in Azure now anytime we store a
container image it provides us an option
for geo replication what that means is
that we can efficiently manage a single
registry replicated across multiple
regions now this Geor replication it
actually enables us to manage Global
deployments assuming we are having an
environment that requires a global
deployment so it helps us to manage
Global deployments as one entity because
we are Geor replicating we would be
updating we would be editing one image
and that image gets replicated
throughout the global uh replication
centers we would have set up and so just
one editing would have actually edited
the global images and those global
images would have provisioned the global
application so one edit replication and
then provisioning of the applications
globalwide and this replication also
helps us to helps us Network latency
because you know anytime an application
needs to deploy it does not have to rely
on a single source which which can be
reach only through high latency Network
because we have Global replications
around the world anytime the application
wants to check back it would check back
uh the application which is in a very
nearby location for the ation itself
Global replication means that we are
managing it as a single entity that's
being replicated across the multiple
regions in the globe as next thing in a
learning let's talk about um Azure
databases now this Azure datab bases are
rational in fact they have uh many
flavors in them uh we're going to look
at uh different of flavors no SQL nosql
cache type of database that Azure offers
so we're going to learn learn one at a
time or we going to learn one by one so
this Azure SQL database is a rational
database in fact it's a rational
database as a service it's managed by
Azure we don't get to do a lot of
management in it so it's a rational
database as a service uh based on
Microsoft uh SQL Server database engine
and this database is a high performance
database it's very reliable and uh it's
very secure as well and this High
reliability high performance and for
this high security we really don't have
to do anything it comes along with it
and uh it's managed by Azure and there
are two things that I definitely need to
mention about Azure SQL database that is
it's an intelligent service number one
it's fully managed by Azure and it also
has this one good thing which is it has
built-in intelligence that learns app
patterns and adapts to maximize
performance and reliability and data
protection of the application that's
something that's not found in uh many of
the other Cloud providers that I'm aware
of so I thought I'll mention it so it
uses built-in intelligence to learn
about the user's database patterns and
helps improve performance and protection
and migration or importing data is very
easy when it comes to Azure SQL database
so it can be readily or immediately used
for analytic reporting and uh
intelligent application
in Azure as next thing let's talk about
Azure cosmod DB now Azure cosmod DB is a
database service that is for no SQL type
and uh it's it's created to provide low
latency and uh an application that
scales dynamically or that scales
rapidly now this Azure cosmod DB is an a
globally distributed service and it's a
multimodel database this can be
provision in a click of a button that's
all all we got to do if we need to
provision and Azure Cosmo DB in the
Azure it helps with scaling the database
now we can elastically and independently
scale throughput and storage across this
database and in any of the azured
geographic regions it provides a good
throughput it provides good latency it
provides good availability and um it
provides or Azure promises a a
comprehensive SLA that uh no other
database can offer that's the best part
about cosmod DB so this cosmod DB was
built with global distribution in mind
and it's built uh with the horizontal
scale in mind and all this we can use by
only paying for what we have used and
remember the difference between Azure
cosmod DB and SQL database is that Azure
cosmod DB supports no SQL whereas SQL
doesn't all right few other things about
Azure cosmod is it allows users to use
key value graph a column family and
document data it also gives users a
number of AP options like SQL JavaScript
mongodb and and few others that you
might want to check at the document at
at the time of reading and the best part
here is that all that we mentioned we
get to use only by paying for the amount
of storage and throughput that are
required and the storage and the
throughput can be elastically scaled
based on the requirement of the r all
right let's talk about um red is cach
discussion about Azure database won't be
complete without we talking about reddis
cache now reddis cach is a secure data
cache it's also called it's also
sometimes called as messaging broker
that provides high throughput and low
latency access to data for the
applications now redis cache is based on
an a popular opsource caching product
which is redis sometimes called as R is
cache now what's the use case it's
typically used to cach to improve the
performance and scalability of a system
that rely heavily on backend data stores
now performance when we use zis cach is
improved by temporarily copying the
frequently accessed data to a fast
storage located very close to the
application now with redish cach this
fast storage is located in memory with
redis cache instead of being loaded from
the actual dis in the database itself
now this redist Cache can also be used
as an inmemory data structure store now
not only that it can be used as an
distributed non- relational database and
a message broker so there are variety of
uh use cases for this redis cache and by
using redis cache the application
performance is improved by taking
advantage of the low latency and the
high throughput performance that this
redis cache engine provides so to
summarize this redis cache when we use
redis cache data is stored in the memory
instead of the disk to ensure that there
is high throughput and low latency when
the application needs to read the data
it provides various levels of scaling
without any downtime or interference now
this red cach is actually backed by redu
server and it supports u a string hashes
linked list and various other data
structures now let's talk about security
and identity Services now identity
management in specific is a process of
authenticating first and then
authorizing using security principles
now not only that identity management
involves controlling information about
those principal identities you might ask
now what's an principal identity now
Identity or principal identity are
Services applications users groups and a
lot more the speciality about uh this
identity management is that it not only
helps authenticate and authorize
principles in Cloud it also helps helps
authenticate and authorize principles or
resources on premises especially when
you run an hybrid Cloud environment so
all these services and features that
this identity management helps us to get
additional level of validation like
identity management can provide
multiactor authentication it can provide
access policies based on condition a
permit or deny based on condition it can
also monitor susp ious activity and not
only that it can also report it it can
also help generate alerts for potential
security issues and in a way to mitigate
it can send us an alert so we can get
involved and prevent and security
accident from happening so let's talk
more about identity management so some
of the services under security and
identity management or Azure security
center now this Azure security Center
provides a Security Management and
threat protection across the workloads
in both cloud and in the hybrid
environment it helps control user access
and application control to stop any
malicious activity if present it helps
us to find and fix vulnerabilities
before they can be even exploited it
integrates very well with analytic
methods that helps us to identify or it
gives us the intelligent to identify or
dedu attacks and prevent them before it
can actually happen and it also works
seamlessly with hybrid environments so
you don't have to have one policy for on
premises and one policy for the cloud
it's now a Unified Service both for on
premises and the cloud the next service
in security and identity would be keyal
now a keyal is a service or a feature
that help safegard the cryptographic
keys and any other Secrets used by by
the cloud applications and the services
in other words this Azure keywall is a
tool for securely storing and accessing
the secrets of the environment I mean
the secret Keys now a secret is anything
that you really want to have a very
tight control access like the
certificates like the passwords stuff
like that now if I tell you what keyword
actually solves that would actually
explain what keywall is now key Al is
used in Secrets management it's helped
in securely storing The Tokens The
passwords the certificates it helps in
Key Management you know it really helps
in creating and controlling the
encryption keys that we would use to
encrypt data it helps in certificate
management talking about certification
management it helps us to easily
provision manage and deploy public and
private SSL TLS certificates in Azure
and a lot more so in a nutshell this key
wall it provides users the ability to
provision new walls and keys in just a
matter of minutes all that in a single
command or all that in a couple of
button clicks it also helps users to
centrally manage their Keys Secrets and
policies next in the list let's talk
about Azure active directory now Azure
active directory it helps us to create
intelligent driven access policies to
limit resource usage and manage user
identities what what does that mean now
this Azure active directory is a
cloudbased active directory and identity
management service now Azure active
directory combines in it's actually a
combination of the core directory
Services Plus application access
management plus identity protection and
one good thing about this Azure in fact
there are a lot of good things but
especially when you're running hybrid
environments you might wonder well how
this Azure active directory is going to
behave now this Azure active directory
is buil to work on on premises and Cloud
environment as well not only that it
also works seamlessly with mobile
applications as well so in a nutshell
this Azure active directory it acts as
an central point of identity and access
management for our Cloud environment it
also provides good Security Solutions
that protect against unauthorized access
of our app and the data now that we have
discussed about security and identity
let's talk about the management tools
that Azure has to offer Azure provides
builtin management and account
governance tools that helps
administrators and developers that helps
them to keep their resources secure and
very compliant and again it helps both
in on premises and in the cloud
environment and these management tools
help us to monitor the infrastructure
monitor the applications it also helps
in provisioning and configuring
resources it also helps in updating apps
it helps in analyzing threats taking
backup of the resources build uh
disaster recoveries it also helps in
applying policies and conditions to
automate our environment we use Azure
management tools and it's also used in
cost control methods so this Azure
management plays a wide role across the
Azure services and in the management
tools first comes the Azure advisor now
this Azure advisor it acts as a guide to
educate us about Azure best practices it
throws recommendations that we can
select on the basis of the category of
servers and it also provides the impact
it can have or the impact that would
happen in our environment if we follow
the recommendations given and
recommendations are first one is the
recommendations are kind of templatized
and it throws um the templatized
recommendations not only that it also
provides customized recommendations on
the basis of the configuration on the
basis of our usage patterns and these
recommendations are not hard it's not
like something that it recommends and
then just leaves us hanging there the
these recommendations provided are very
easy to follow very easy to implement
and see results you can think of aure
advisor as an a Very personalized Cloud
consultant that helps you to follow best
practices to optimize our deployments it
kind of analyzes our resources our
configurations our usage and then it
recommends a solution for us that really
helps in improving the cost
Effectiveness improving the performance
improving High availability and
improving Security in our Azure
environment so with this Azure advisor
we can get a proactive actionable and
personalized best practice
recommendations now you don't have to be
an expert just follow the Azure advisor
and your environment is going to be good
it also helps and improve the
performance security High availability
of our environment and also it helps in
bringing down the overall Azure spent
and the best part is it's a free service
that analyzes our Azure usage and
provides recommendations how we can
optimize our Azure resource to reduce
cost and reduce cost at the same time
boost the performance helps in
strengthening the security and improve
the overall reliability of our
environment next in the list would be
Network Watcher now this network Watcher
helps users identify and gain insights
in the the overall Network performance
and the health of the overall
environment now these Azure Watchers
provides enough tools to monitor to
diagnose to view the metrics and to
enable or disable logs which means you
to generate and collect the logs for
resources in the Azure virtual Network
so with network Watcher can monitor and
diagnose issues in networking without
even logging into the virtual machines
with just the logs which are real time
we can actually come to a conclusion
what could be wrong in a certain
resource in a VM or in a database you
know but just looking at the logs and
not only that it's used for analytic or
to gain some intelligence of what's
happening in our Network we can gain a
lot of insight to the current Network
traffic pattern using the security group
flow logs that this network Watcher
offers it also helps in investigating
VPN connectivity issues using detailed
logs now you might or might not know
that you know VPN troubleshooting
requires both parties or it involves two
parties other person the network
administrator on this side and the
network administrator on the other side
and they will have to check logs in
their end and we'll have to check logs
in our end stuff like that but with the
network Watcher it kind of takes it to
the next level the logs itself we could
easily identify which which side is
having the issue and suggest an
appropriate fix and the next in the list
would be Microsoft Azure portal now this
Microsoft aure portal it provides a
single unified console to perform
various number of activities like
building not only building managing and
monitoring the web applications that we
build now this portal can be used to
organize our environment or the
appearance of the environment or or the
visual of the environment based on our
workstyle and using Azure portal users
can control who gets to manage or access
the resources all from the Azure portal
and this Azure portal gives a very good
visibility on the spend that happen on
each resource right and if we can
customize it we can also identify spend
based on team spend based on days spend
based on Department stuff like that so
it kind of gives us a good visual of
where the money is spending or where is
the bill consumed within the Azure
environment next in the list would be
Azure resource manager now Azure
resource manager enables us to manage
the usage of the application resources
now we use resource manager to deploy
Monitor and manage solution resources as
a group as if it's one single entity now
the infrastructure of our application is
typically made of various components
which includes virtual machine storage
virtual Network web app database servers
some other third party services that we
might use in our environment and they
are by nature separate services but with
Azure resource manager we don't see them
as different components or different
entities instead we see them as related
services in a group that supports and
application now we kind of get the
relation between them instead of you
know letting them spread Azure resource
manager identifies the relation between
them and helps us to visually see them
all as one or single entity not only
that Azure resource manager helps or it
ensures that the resources that we
provision or deploy at a constant rate
along with the other application it also
helps users to visually see their
resources and how they are connected and
that helps in managing the resources a
lot better resource Group also is used
to control who can access the resources
within the user's organization kind of
gives you the fine grain control over
who gets to access and who does not get
access and the last one in the
management tools would be Automation and
this automation gives us the ability to
automate configure and install upgrades
across hybrid environments it provides a
cloud-based Automation and configuration
service not only that this can be
applied for non aure environments as
well which is on premises so some of the
automation we could do is process
automation update management automation
configuration features automation stuff
like that and this Azure automation
provides complete control during the
deployment operation and also during the
decommissioning of the workloads and
resources with automation we can
actually automate uh time consuming or
mundane or any task that's error prone
because of uh human errors those things
can be automated so irrespective of how
many times you run it it's going to run
the same way and that really helps in
reducing the overall time and also the
overhead cost because a lot of the
things are automated which means it's
human error free which which means the
application is not going to break and
keep running for a longer time with
automation we can actually build a good
inventory of operating system resources
and configuration items all in one place
with ease and this really helps in
tracking the changes and investigating
the issue let's say something happened
because we have automation because it's
logging the configuration changes it's
easy to track easy to identify easy to
identify what has changed lately that
has broken broken the environment go
back and fix it or kind of roll it back
that solves the problem and that
actually summarizes the aure management
tools or Management Services now let's
talk about the networking tools or the
networking services available in Azure
there are variety of services especially
networking services that Azure offers
and I'm sure it's going to be an
interesting one let's begin our
discussion with content delivery Network
now the content delivery Network in
short CDN it allows us to perform secure
and a very reliable content delivery not
only that it also helps in accelerating
the delivery time or in other words
reducing the delivery time also called
as load times it also helps in Saving
bandwidth and increases in
responsiveness to the application let's
expand on this the content delivery
network is actually a distributed
network of servers that can efficiently
deliver web content to users now CDN
we're going to use the word CDN here CDN
store cached content on global Edge
servers also called as uh pops point of
presence locations that are very close
to the end users so the latency is
minimized it's like taking a copy of the
data or taking a multiple copy of the
data and storing it in different parts
of the world and whoever is requesting
it the data gets delivered to them from
a server which is very locally to them
so this CDN offers developers a global
solution for rapidly delivering high
bandwidth content to users by caching
the content in a strategically placed
location which is very near to them so
these content delivery networks it
really helps in handling that's one
advantage you get for Content delivery
Network that's we can handle spikes and
heavy loads very efficiently and we can
also run analytic against the logs that
gets generated in content delivery
Network which helps in gaining good
Insight on the workflow and what would
be the future business need for that
application and this just like a lot of
other services this is on a pay as you
go type so you use the resource first
and then you only pay for what you have
used the next one in working would be
express route now express route is
actually a circuit or a link that
provides an a direct private connection
to Azure and because it's direct it
gives low latency link to Azure it gives
good speed and reliability for the Azure
data transfer it could be on premises to
Azure so it gives very good speed it
gives increased reliability and low
latency for that connection let's expand
on this a bit now this express route is
an service that actually provides an
private connection between Microsoft
Data Center and infrastructure in our
premises or in a different cocation
facility that we might have now these
Express routes do not go over the public
internet and because they don't go over
the public internet they offer high
security reliability and speed and low
latency compared to the connections
which are in the internet because it's
fast because it's reliable because it it
has low latency it can be used as an
extension of our existing data center
you know users are not going to feel the
difference whether they are accessing
services from and on premises or in the
cloud environment because latency is
minimized as much as possible users are
really not going to see the difference
and because it's a private line and not
an public internet line it can be used
to build hybrid applications without
compromising privacy or the performance
now these virtual private Cloud these
Express routes can be used for taking
backups ifum a backup going through the
internet that would be a nightmare if
you use express route for backups that's
going to be fast and imagine recovering
a data through the internet from the
cloud through the internet to the on
premises in a time of disaster that
would be the wor nightmare so these
Express routes can be used not only to
backup but also to recover the data
because it provides good speed low
latency recovering the data is going to
be lot sooner the next product or
service we're going to discuss in
networking is azure DNS now Azure DNS
allows us to host domain name in Azure
and these domain names come with an
exceptional performance and availability
now azure DNS is used to set up and
manage DNS zones and records for our
domain name in the cloud now this Azure
DNS is a service for DNS just like the
name says and it provides name
resolution by using azures
infrastructure and uh by using this
domain we can actually manage the DNS
ourselves through the Azure portal with
the same credential imagine having a DNS
provider which does not even belong in
our it imagine that environment you know
we would have a separate portal to
manage the DNS environment now those are
gone and now we can actually manage the
DNS in the very same Azure portal where
we use the rest of the other services
and this Azure DNS very much integrates
with other DNS service providers it uses
a Global Network of name servers to
provide fast response to DNS queries and
these domains are having additional
avail avability compared to the other uh
domain service providers availability
promises these are going to have more
availability than the rest because most
of the servers are maintained by
Microsoft and it helps resolve sooner it
helps resyncing let's say a server fails
it kind of helps resyncing with the rest
of the servers so all the Microsoft's
environment all the Microsoft's Global
Network of name servers kind of ensures
that our domain names are resolved
properly not only properly but also are
available most of the time right next in
the list in networking Services is
virtual Network I'm sure this is going
to be very interesting and I'm sure
you're going to like it so this
networking or virtual networking in
Azure it actually allows us to set up
our own private cloud in the public
Cloud it gives us an isolated and highly
secure envirment rment for our
application let's expand on this and
this Azure virtual Network helps us to
provision Azure virtual machines and uh
it helps us to securely communicate with
other on premises and internet networks
it also helps in controlling the traffic
that flows through or Flows In and Out
of This virtual Network to other virtual
networks and to the internet now this
Azure virtual Network sometimes called
as vet is actually a representation of
our own network in the cloud it's
actually a logical isolation of the
Azure Cloud dedicated to our
subscription all our environments are
provisioned in a v-net that is separate
from another customers wets that way we
have that logical separation there so
this virtual Network can also be used to
provision VPN in the cloud so we can
connect the cloud and the on premises uh
in infrastructure and a lot more
especially in a environment where we
have hybrid environment surely we will
be using virtual Network because that's
going to require VPN for secure data
transfer in and out of the cloud and in
and out of the on premises environment
all right so it kind of gives us an
boundary for all the resources so all
the traffic between the Azure resources
they kind of logically stay in between
or logic stay within the Azure virtual
Network and here we can design the
network it's given over to us you know
you can pick the IP you can pick the
routing you can pick the subnet and a
lot of freedom is given or I would say a
lot of control on how the network is
designed it's not like something that's
already cooked and we only get to use it
no we can actually build the network
from the scratch we can pick the IP
address that we like we can pick you
know which subnet needs to communicate
with the other subnet stuff like that
and like I said if you are using hybrid
environment you definitely would be
requiring a virtual Network because it
helps connect the on premises and the
cloud in a secure fashion using VPN the
last product we're going to discuss in
networking is a load balancer this load
balancer actually provides application a
good availability and a good Network
performance so how does it work it
actually works by load balancing the
traffic to and from uh the virtual
machine and the cloud resources not only
that it also load balances between cloud
and cross premises virtual networks with
azured load balancer we can actually
scale our application and create high
availability for our services which
means our application will be available
most of the time if any of the server
goes dead the server does not get
traffic what happens if the server gets
traffic user is going to experience
downtime what happens if the server does
not get traffic user won't experience
any downtime the connection is shifted
to an healthy service so the user
experiences uptime all the time so this
load balancer supports inbound and
outbound scenarios and it provides low
latency it gives high throughput of the
data transfer and we can actually scale
up the flow of the TCP and UDP
connections from hundreds to thousands
to even Millions because we have a load
B balancer now in between the user and
the application so how does it operate
this load balancer actually receives the
traffic and it load balances the traffic
to the backend pool of instances
connected to it according to the rule
and the health probe that we set that's
how it maintains High availability so
what does load balancer help it helps in
creation of high available scalable
application in the cloud in minutes it
can be used to automatically scale the
en environment with the increasing
application traffic and one feature of
load balancer is to check the health of
the user application instance and it
removes or it stops sending the request
to the unhealthy instance and kind of
shifts that connection to the healthy
instance that way a user or a connection
does not get stuck with an instance
That's not healthy that's all that you
need to know about the networking
Services now let's talk about the
storage services or the storage domain
in Azure now azzure storage in general
is a a Microsoft manage service
providing cloud storage which basically
is highly available secure durable
scalable and redundant because it's all
managed by Azure we don't get to manage
a lot of it and these Azure storages are
a group of storage Services they catter
different needs and the storage products
include Azure blobs which is actually an
object storage it includes a Azure data
Lake it includes Azure files as you see
it it includes Azure cues it includes
Azure tables and lot more but let's
start our discussion with Azure store
simple Azure store simple is an hybrid
cloud storage solution that actually
lowers the cost of storage to nearly 60%
of how much you would be actually
spending without using it so aure simple
storage or store simple is an integrated
storage solution that manages the
storage task between on premises and the
cloud storage what I really like about
Azure is that it's built around hybrid
environment in mind there are a lot of
other Cloud providers that are there
where running and hybrid environment is
a big challenge you know it has some
compatibility you won't be able to find
an hybrid or un premises and Cloud
solution for your need stuff like that
but with the Azure especially when it
comes to storage a lot of the things
that we're going to see it clearly is
designed with hybrid environment in mind
all right so let's come back and talk
about store simple so store simple is an
very efficient cost effective and a very
easily manageable sand storage area
networking solution in the cloud I
thought I'll throw in this information
the reason why it got store simple is
really because it uses store simple 8000
series devices which are used in Azure
Data Center and this uh store simple or
simple storage it comes along on with
storage steering to manage the stored
data across the various storage media so
the current the very current data is
actually stored in on premises on solid
state drives and data that is used less
frequently is stored in uh hdds or hard
disk drives and the data that requires
archived or that needs to be archived
very old data let's say less frequently
used data candidate for archive they are
actually pushed to the cloud so you see
how this storage steering automatically
happens in store simple and one another
cool feature of store simple is that it
enables us to create an on demand and
scheduled backups of data and then store
the data locally or in the cloud and
these backups are actually taken in the
form of incremental snapshot which means
that they can be created and restored
quickly it's not a complete backup it's
an incremental backup and these Cloud
snapshots they can be critically
important when there is a disaster and
when there is a disaster recovery
scenario because these snapshots can be
called in and they can be put on storage
systems and then they become the actual
data so recovering is faster if you have
proper scheduled backups or if you have
frequent backups and this storage simple
it really helps in easing our backup
mechanism which means it kind of eases
our Disaster Recovery steps or
procedures as well so this store simple
it can be used to automate data
management data migration data movement
data teering across the Enterprise both
in cloud and on premises it actually
improves the compliance and accelerates
the disaster recovery for our
environment and if there is one thing
that's increasing every new day in our
environment that would be storage and
this store simple addresses that need
and we really don't have to pre-plan or
or think in deep or having a proper
storage because now we have a simple
storage available in the cloud and
moreover it's on a pay as youo type so
not much pre-planning on storage is
needed yes there would be a need but not
as much as I would without the cloud or
without the simple storage and the next
service under the storage that we would
like to discuss is the data Lake store
this data Lake store or storage it's a
cost effective solution for big data
analytics in specific so let's expand
this so this is data Lake storage is an
enterprise-wide repository for big data
analytic workload now that's the major
service that's dependent on this data
Lake store and this data Lake enables us
to capture data of any size of any type
and of any injection speed and it kind
of collects them in one single space or
in one single place for operational
efficiency I mean operational efficiency
and for an altic purpose hadu in Azure
is very dependent on this data Lake
storage and this data Lake store is
designed with performance for analytics
in mind so anytime you think of or
anytime you're using analytic in the
cloud or anytime you're using Hado in
the cloud in Azure we are definitely
using or we will be to the most part or
the normal procedure or the Right
Storage to pick would be data Lake store
in Azure it's designed with security in
mind so anytime we use Azure storage we
can be rest assured that we are using
storage from within a data center which
has or which was built with security in
mind so this data store also uses Azure
blob storage behind the scenes for
global scale durability and for
performance let's talk about blob
storage now blob storage provides large
amount of storage and scalability now
this blob storage is the object storage
solution for Azure Cloud let's expand a
bit on blob storage Azure blob storage
is Microsoft offering for object storage
now this blob storage is optimized for
storing massive amount of unstructured
data which could be text or binary data
it's designed and it's optimized for
Rapid reads if I explain to you on what
scenarios we would be using blob storage
that might help you get a good
understanding of what blob storage is is
so it's helped or it's designed as of
now it's being used in many it
environments to serve images or
documents directly to the browser it
helps in storing files for distributed
access a lot of Fetchers can fetch data
from Azure blob storage and it currently
helping users stream video and audio
it's currently being used for writing
log files it's currently being used to
store data as backup and restore at a
later point in times of Disaster
Recovery it also is used as an archiving
storage in a lot of cloud it
environments it's widely used in storing
analytic data not only storing but also
running analytic query against the data
stored in it so that's a wide use case
for blob storage not only that in
addition to all that we mentioned uh it
also supports versioning so anytime
somebody updates and data a new version
gets created which means at any point I
and roll back as in when needed and it
provides a lot of flexibility on
optimizing the users storage need it
also supports uh tearing of the data So
based on need when I actually explore I
would find a lot of options I can pick
from that uh you know suits to my unique
storage environment or unique storage
need and like I said it stores
unstructured data and this unstructured
data is available for customers through
rest based uh object storage environment
the next product and storage service
would be Q storage now Q storage
provides durable cues for large volume
cloud services it's a very simple and a
cost effective durable messaging queue
for large workloads let's expand this Q
storage for a moment now this Q storage
is a service for storing large amount of
messages that can be accessed from
anywhere in the world through HTTP and
https call fals a single CU or a single
CU message can be up to like 24 KB in
size and a single Q can contain millions
of such 24 KB in size messages and how
much can it hold it can hold up to the
total capacity of the storage account
itself so that's kind of easy to
translate How much would it hold and
this Azure Q storage it provides an
messaging solution between applications
and components in in the cloud what does
it help it helps in designing an
application for scale it helps in
decoupling the application so you know
it's not very dependent or sometimes
it's not at all dependent on the other
application because now we have a queue
in between which kind of translates or
which kind of connects or which kind of
decouples both the environment now we
have a queue in between both the
environment can scale up or scale down
independently the next next in the
storage service would be file storage
let's talk about file storage now these
Azure files provide secure simple and
managed Cloud file shares now with file
share in the cloud it actually extends
the user servers on premises performance
and capacity and lot of familiar tools
for the cloud file share management can
be used along with the file storage that
we're talking about so let's expand a
bit on file storage now this Azure files
or Azure file storage offers a fully
managed file shares in the cloud that
can be accessed via the uh SMB protocol
server message block protocol now this
Azure file shares can be mounted
concurrently by cloud or in on premises
deployments a lot of operating systems
are compatible with it windows are
compatible Linux is compatible Mac OS is
compatible in in addition to all these
being able to run on on premises and on
the cloud or being able to access from
on premises and on the cloud it can also
offer cash for caching the data and
keeping it locally so it's immediately
available when needed so that's some
additional feature I would say that's
some Advanced feature that it offers
compared to the other file shares
available in the market let's talk about
table storage let's talk about table
storage now table storage is a nosql key
value pair storage for quick deployments
with the large semi-structured data sets
the difference between one important
thing to note with table storage is that
it has a flexible data schema and also
it's highly available let's expand a bit
on uh table storage so anytime you want
to pick a schema less a no SQL type
table storage is the one will end up
picking it provides an key pair
attribute storage with a schema less
design this table storage is very fast
and very coste effective for many of the
applications and for the same amount of
uh data it's a lot cheaper when you
compare it with the traditional SQL data
or data storage so some of the things
that we can store in the table storage
are of course they're going to be
flexible data sheets uh such as user
data for web application address books
device information and other types of
metadata for our service requirements
and it can have any number of tables up
to the capacity limit of the storage
account now this is not possible with
SQL this is only possible with no SQL
especially with table storage in Azure
explanation of storage really concluded
the length and breadth of the
explanation this CEO was giving his uh
it personal but this ID Personnel is not
done with it yet he still has a question
even after after this lengthy discussion
and his question was well there are a
lot of other Cloud providers available
what made you specifically choose Azure
I mean from the kind of question that he
asked we can say that he is very curious
and uh he definitely had asked and very
thoughtful question so his CEO went on
and started to explain about the uh
other capabilities of azure or how it
kind of outruns the rest of the cloud
providers so started or he again started
his discussion but from a different
angle now so he started to explain what
are the capabilities or how Azure is
better than uh the competitor so he
started with explaining the platform as
a service capabilities and I'm going to
tell you what the CEO told his ID person
so this platform as a service or in
platform as a service the infrastructure
management is completely taken care by
uh Microsoft allowing users to focus
completely on the innovation no more
infrastructure management
responsibilities go and focus on
Innovation that's that's a fancy way of
saying it when we buy platform as a
service that's what we get we can
contribute our time on Innovation and
not just maintaining the infrastructure
and U Azure especially is U net friendly
Azure supports the net programming
language and um it has or it is built or
designed or it is optimized to work with
old and new applications deployed using
net programming framework so if your
application is net most of the time you
would end up picking Azure I mean if you
try to compare most of the time you
would end up picking Azure as your cloud
service provider and the security
offerings that Azure offers is it's
designed based on the security
development uh life cycle which is an
industry-leading assurance process when
we buy services from azure it assures
that the environment is designed based
on security development life cycle and
like I mentioned many times in the past
and I would like to mention it again
Azure has well thought about the hybrid
environments which a lot of other Cloud
providers have failed so it's very easy
to set up an hybrid environment to
migrate the data or not to migrate the
data and still run a hybrid environment
they work seamlessly with the Azure
because Azure provides seamless
connection across on premises data
centers and the public Cloud it also has
a very gentle learning curve if you look
at the documentation it's picture rich
and the documentations are neat and
clear with really it would encourage you
to learn more it would encourage you to
think and imagine and try easily get a
grasp of how Services work so it has a
very gentle learning curve Azure allows
the utilization of tech technologies
that several business have used for
years so there is a big history behind
it it has a very gentle learning curve
that the certifications the
documentations the stage-by-stage
certification levels it's all very
gentle learning curve which is generally
missing in other cloud service providers
now this would really impress the CTO or
or people working in finance and
budgeting if an organization is already
using Microsoft software they can
definitely go and Avail or be bold and
ask for a discount that can reduce the
overall Azure spending in other words
overall pricing of the Azure so that's
what helped or they are the information
that helped the CEO pick Azure as his
cloud service provider and then the CEO
goes on and talks about the different
companies that are currently using Azure
and they are definitely using Azure for
a reason like Pixar Boeing Samsung
EasyJet Zur BMW 3M they are major
multinational multi-billion companies
they rely run operate their it in Azure
and this CEO has a thought that his it
person is still not very convinced
unless and until he shows him a visual
of how easy things are in Azure so he
goes on and explains about a practical
application of azure which is what
exactly I'm going to show you as well
all right a quick project on on building
an Azure app using or building a net
application in Azure web app and making
it connect to an SQL database will
solidify all the knowledge that we have
gained so far so this is what we're
going to do I have an Azure account open
as you see logged in and everything is
fresh here let me go to Resource Group
there's nothing in there it's it's kind
of fresh all right I'm logged in and
this is what we're going to do so we're
going to we going to create an
application like this which is nothing
but an to-do application a to-do list
application which is going to run from
the web app get information from us and
save it in the database that's connected
to it so you can already see it's a two
tier application web and DB all right so
let me go back to my Azure account the
first thing is to create an Resource
Group let's give it an a meaningful name
let's call it Azure simply Lear all
right and it's going to be a free trial
and the location pick one that's nearest
to you or you know wherever you want to
launch your application now for this use
case I'm going to pick Central us and
create it's going to take a while to get
created there you go it's created it's
called Azure simply learn now what do we
need we need an web app and an a
separate SQL database let's first get
our web app running so go to app
services and then click on ADD it's not
the web app plus SQL that we want we
want web app alone for this uh example
so let's create an web app uh give it a
quick name let's call it U Azure simply
learn the subscription is free trial and
I'm going to use my existing Resource
Group a resource Group that we created
some time back it's going to run out of
Windows and we're going to publish the
code all set we can create it all right
while this is running uh let me create
my uh
database right SQL database create a
database give it a name let's call it
Azure simply learn
DB put it in our existing Resource Group
that we created it's going to be a blank
database all right and it's going to
require some uh set settings like the
name of the server and the admin login
the password that goes along and in
which location this is going to be
created the server name is going to be
Azure simply learn DB that's the server
name and the admin login can be what can
be the admin login name let's see so
let's call it simply La that's my admin
login name and let me pick a
password
click on create so what have we done so
far we have created an web app and we
have created an uh a database in the
resource Group that we have created so
if I go to Resource Group it's going to
take some time before things show up so
if I go to my Resource Group I only have
one Resource Group as of now as you
simply learn and there I have a bunch of
resources being created you know it's
still being created all right in the
meantime I have my application right
here that's running out of uh or that's
in Visual Studio as of now right so once
the infrastructure is set and ready in
the Azure console uh we're going to go
back to visual studio I feed these
inputs in the visual studio so the code
knows what the database is the the
credentials to log into the database
stuff like that so we're going to feed
those information in Visual Studio here
by that we're actually feeding it into
the application and then we're going to
run it from there deploying this
application takes uh quite a while we
really got to be patient all right now
we have all the resources that we need
for the application to run here is my uh
database and here is my app service
there's one more thing we need to do
that is um create an firewall exception
rule so one more thing needed is to
create an firewall exception uh rule
right so the application is going to run
from my local desktop and it's going to
connect to the uh uh database right so
let's add an exception rule by simply
adding the client IP it's going to pick
my IP the IP of laptop I'm using as of
now and it's going to create an
exception to access the database so
that's done now we can go back to our
Visual Studio I already have a couple of
um apps running or couple of
configurations pushed from Visual Studio
I'm going to clean that up if you're
doing it for the first time you you may
not uh need to do
this all right so let's start from the
scratch this is very similar to how you
would be doing in your environment all
right so we're going to uh select an
existing Azure app service now before
that I have logged in as you can see I
have logged in with my credential so
it's going to pull few things
automatically from my Azure account so
in this case I'm going to use an
existing Azure app so select existing
and then click on
publish all right if you recall these
are the very same resources that we
created a while
back
right we have clicked on Save and it's
running kind of validating the code and
it's going to come up with an URL now
initially the URL is uh not going to
work because we haven't mapped the
application to the database that would
be the next
thing all right so the app has been
published and it's running from my uh
web app as of now it's going to throw an
error like you see it's throwing an
error that's because we haven't mapped
the app and the DB together so let's do
that all right let's do that so let's go
to server Explorer uh this is where uh
we're going to see our uh databases that
we have created now let's quickly verify
that
go back to uh the resource Group right
appropriate Resource Group which is
right here and uh here I have my uh
database Azure simply learn
database
all right it has some issues connecting
uh to my database give me a quick moment
let's fix
it
all right so we'll have to map the
database into this application all right
so let's go to the solution Explorer
click on
publish and a page like this get shown
and from here we can go to
configure here is our web app all right
with all its uh credentials let's
validate the connection number
one all right and then click on
next this is my DB connection string
right which the app is going to use to
connect to my DB now if you recall rdb
was uh Azure simply learn DB and that's
not being shown here so let's fix
that right so let's fix
that click on configure and here uh
let's put our DB servers uh URL now
before that let's change this to SQL
Server all right and then in here uh put
the DB's URL so go back to azure here is
my DB or serers name put that
here right the username to connect to
the server that's right here put that in
and the
password to connect to the server let's
put that
in all right it's trying to connect to
our Azure portal or the Azure
infrastructure and here here is my
database if you recall it's Azure sldb
that's the name of the database Let's
test the connection connection is good
click on
okay so now it's showing up correctly
Azure simply learn DB that's the name of
uh the database that we created now it's
configured
all right let's modify the data
connections right let's map it to the
appropriate database again all right so
our name of the database is azure simply
Lear
DB and then uh it's going to be SQL
Server that's the data
source the
uh username is simply learn and the
password is what we have given in the
beginning all right let's validate the
connection it's good click
okay now we're all set and ready to
publish our application again now the
application knows how to connect uh to
the database we have educated it with
the um the correct connection strings
the DNS name the username and the
password for the application to connect
to the
database so the visual studi is building
this project and once it is up and
running we'll be prompted with an URL uh
to connect and anytime we put or we give
inputs to the URL that's going to
receive the input and save it in the
database
all right so here is my uh to-do list
app and uh I can start uh creating to-do
list for myself all right so I have
items already listed I can create an
entry and these entries get stored in
the U in the database I can create
another entry and I'll take the dog for
a walk that's going to get stored I can
create another entry uh book tickets for
uh scientific U
exhibition and that's going to receive
and put that in the database and that
concludes our session so through this
session we saw how I can use Azure
services to create web app and connect
that to the DB instance and how those
two Services which are decoupled by
default which are separate by default
how I can you know use the connection
strings to make connection between the
app server and the database and be able
to create an working app I strongly
believe you enjoyed me walking you
through this session so if you are
interested in becoming an Azure
certified professional then consider
simply learns Azure Cloud architect
Masters program Azure Cloud architect
Masters program will help you master the
Azure infrastructure by understanding
Azure Cloud architect Technology
Solutions implementing workloads and
Security in Azure creating and deploying
apps in azure and securing data in aob
now who should take this program fresher
graduates who are intent on taking the
plunge into the job market second
professionals with less than two years
of experience who are working in either
technical or non-technical job rules and
want to shift to the cloud so what are
you waiting for and roll now get
certified and get ahead I'd like to
welcome all of you to this training
video on a so here we have two friends
having a conversation with each other
one of them says that her company is
moving all of its physical data and
migrating it onto the cloud she says
that they're using a cloud service
provider known as a z now here's the
problem she doesn't really understand
how cloud service providers work or even
how the cloud does her friend decides to
help her out so in this video here's
what we're going to talk about first
we'll talk about what is cloud computing
what is Microsoft a your what are the
services that aour offers and then we'll
have a look at a use case where we'll be
applying one of of these services to get
a particular job done now for the first
question what is cloud computing so
cloud computing actually provides a
platform through which you can access
resources now these resources include
servers storage application security and
other ways you can transform your data
or get some use out of it now at the
same time you can also store manage and
process your data now anything related
to cloud computing is made possible only
with the help of the internet now along
with these things there are several
other things that you can do with cloud
computing now let's have a look at some
of the ways cloud computing is making
our lives better firstly you have
services for just about every
requirement that you have then you get
access to the newest and most Innovative
Technologies in the market right now
cloud computing provides cost effective
Solutions with flexible pricing now most
cloud service providers work in such a
way that you only pay for the amount of
time you use that particular resource
then you have one of the most important
selling points when it comes to cloud
computing which is that data and
applications are accessible from any
part of the world as long as you have
access to the internet and finally you
have increased protection for your data
and applications now you should know
that there are several cloud service
providers in the market right now be it
Amazon web services Adobe Creative Cloud
Google Cloud platform and so much more
now among all these platforms there's
one that's growing really really fast
and that is Microsoft AO now let's ask
the question what is Microsoft aor
Microsoft aure is actually a cloud
service platform that allows users to
build manage scale and deploy
applications by giving them access to
cloud services now these cloud services
range from creating virtual machines to
creating functions that run themselves
without having to worry about Hardware
now all of this is made possible only
through the internet now here are some
things that you need to know about a y
firstly it was launched on the 1st of
February 2010 it has data centers in
more than 42 regions across the world
they also say that 12 more data centers
are in the making which helps them say
they're the only cloud service provider
that covers these many regions next aor
is preferred by 80% of the Fortune 500
companies which means that the best of
the best in the market only choose to
work with Azor and finally Azor is the
second largest cloud service provider in
the market right now let's talk about
Azia Services as I told you AZ provides
services for a wide range of domains now
let's have a look at some of these
domains there's Ai and machine learning
compute containers database identity m
management tools networking Security
Storage and so much more now let's have
a look at some of the individual
services within these domains firstly
you have AZ virtual machines with Azure
virtual machines what you get is the
opportunity to create Windows or Linux
virtual machines now all of this is
possible in a matter of seconds with the
large amount of customization now let's
have a look at some of its features
firstly you can choose from a wide
variety of virtual machine options then
you have a large amount of optimization
available to you for example what what
size of operating system do you want how
much size do you want allocated to it
what version of the system is it and so
much more then it provides low cost and
permanent billing now Azo provides you
permanent billing which means that
you're only charged for how much time
you use the service and finally you have
enhanced security and protection for
your virtual machines next we have
service fabric now with service fabric
you have a platform which enables you to
create microservices now this also makes
the process of application life cycle
management a whole lot easier as a
direct result you can create
applications with a faster time to
Market it supports Windows Linux on
premises or other clouds and it enables
you to do a tremendous amount of scaling
up depending on your requirement and
finally we have functions now with
functions you can build applications
with the help of serverless computing
here the users only pay for the amount
of resources that they've used you can
create applications in any language that
you want and the only thing you need to
worry about is the code of the
application everything other than that
that is the hardware requirements are
taken care of by Azure now let's have a
look at the networking Services firstly
we have the Azor CDN or the content
delivery network with Azure CDN what you
get is the ability to deliver your
content with reduced load times fast
responsiveness and less bandwidth now
CDN can be integrated with several other
Azure services so that the process can
move at a fast rate it can handle heavy
loads and traffic spikes with ease it
also provides a robust security system
now with the content that's delivered
you can get Advanced analytic data with
which you can understand how customers
are using your content next we have
express route with express route you can
connect your on premisis network to aure
through a private Network Now by default
this lowest latency it increases the
emphasis on reliability and speed and it
can be of great use when you have to
transfer large amounts of data between
networks now another way this can be
useful is if it's it's used to add
compute or storage capacity to Data
Centers next we have Azure DNS domain
name service or Azure DNS can be used to
host your domains on Azure this provides
High availability and great performance
it provides fast responses to DNS
queries by taking advantage of
Microsoft's Global Network it also
provides High availability next we have
virtual Network AO virtual Network
allows the Azo resources to communicate
with each other or other on promise
networks while via the Internet and all
of this is kept extremely secure now
with this users can create their own
private Network for communication it
provides users with an isolated and
extremely secure environment for their
applications to run now all of the
traffic stays entirely within a your
network and it also allows users to
design their own networks next we have
traffic manager now with traffic manager
you can route incoming traffic to
improve your performance and
availability now one thing it provides
is multiple failover options so if a
particular situation goes wrong there's
always an option to consider to salvage
the situation it helps reduce
application runtime and enables the
distribution of user traffic across
multiple locations it also helps the
people who are using it to know where
the customers connecting from across the
world next we have load balancer with
this you have provided the ability to
instantly scale applications at the same
time providing High availability and
improved Network performance for users
applications it can be integrated into
virtual machines and cloud services it
provides highly reliable applications it
also allows users to secure and
integrate security groups finally we
have Azure VPN Gateway now this allows
users to connect their on promise
networks to aor using a sight tosite VPN
now this allows users to connect their
virtual machine to anywhere in the world
through a pointto site VPN and also it's
very easy to manage and is highly
available now let's talk about the
storage services
first we have data Lake storage now with
this what you get is a scalable data
storage with an emphasis on cost
Effectiveness and scalability now it
comes of Maximum use when you've
integrated with other services so that
you can get analytics on how the data is
being used it is also integrated with
other services like the Azo blob storage
now it is also optimized for Big Data
analysis tools like Pache spark and
Hadoop next up we have blob storage now
blob storage provides a stor storage
capacity for data now depending on how
often a particular data is used it is
classified into different tiers now all
the data that is within the blob storage
is unstructured data now it has a way of
ensuring that the data Integrity is
maintained every time a particular
object is being changed or the data is
being accessed and it also helps improve
app performance and reduces bandwidth
consumption next we have q storage now
with this you have a message queuing
system for large workloads this allows
users to build flexible applications and
separate functions not to mention with
this you can be sure that your
individual components will not fail it
also makes sure that your application is
scalable Q storage provides Q monitoring
which helps ensure that the customer
demands are met then we have file
storage now with file storage you can
perform file sharing with the help of
the SMB protocol or the server message
block protocol now this data is
protected by SMB 3.0 and the https
protocol in this CL like we mentioned in
functions Azo takes care of all the
hardware needs and the operating system
deployments on its own it also improves
on prises performance and other
capabilities lastly we have table
storage with table storage you can
deploy semi-structured data sets and
nosql key value store now this is used
for creating applications which have a
flexible data schema and also
considering how it has a very strong
consistency model it's mainly aimed for
enterprices
next let's have a look at some web and
mobile services first we have the AZ
search now with Azure search you get a
cloud search service which is powered by
artificial intelligence with this you
can develop web applications as well as
mobile applications now one big
Advantage is that you don't have to set
up or manage your search indices aure
takes care of that and by extension it
increases your development speed the
artificial intelligence also will
provide insights and structured
information that you can use to improve
the search and structured information
next we have logic apps now with this
you can create integration Solutions
which can connect applications that are
important to your business now with this
you can visually create business
processes and workflows you can
integrate SAS or software as a service
applications and Enterprise applications
and more importantly it allows you to
unlock data within a firewall and
securely connect to services next we
have web applications now with web web
apps you can create deploy and scale web
applications according to business
requirements now it supports both
windows and Linux platforms and it helps
with continuous integration or
deployment abilities another very
important aspect of this is that the
data can be deployed and hosted across
multiple locations in the world and
finally we have mobile apps with mobile
apps you can create applications for iOS
Android and Windows platforms one
advantage is that it automatically
scales up and down based on your
requirements now in situations where you
have network issues offline data syncing
ensures that your applications work
anyway and you can create crossplatform
applications or native applications for
iOS Android and Windows next let's have
a look at some container services first
let's talk about ACS or Azo container
services it is also known as the Azo
kubernets Services as it's a fully
managed kubernets container
orchestration service now what this
means is that it eases the process of
container integration and deployment it
also can be used with other resources
from security like virtual networks
cryptographic keys and so much more to
ensure that your container is kept
secure next we have container instances
now this is similar to functions in a
way just that in this we're using
containers without having to manage
servers now applications can be
developed here without managing virtual
machines or learning new tools all that
is a your's problem to take care of and
it enables building applications without
having to manage the infrastructure that
is all you need to worry about is
running the container next let's have a
look at some database Services first we
have the SQL database now with SQL
database what you get is a relational
Cloud database service now this means
that it helps accelerate your app
development and makes it easier for you
to maintain your application now SQL
database is also used extensively in
migrating workloads to the cloud and
hence saves time and cost it also helps
improve your performance by integrating
machine learning and Adaptive
Technologies into your database next we
have Azor Cosmos DB now this is a
globally distributed multimodel database
service now what this means is that with
this you can create application with
support nosql it provides a high-grade
security system has high availability
and low latency now this is usually used
in situations where you have a diverse
and highly unpredictable workload now
let's have a look at some security and
identity Services firstly we have the
Azure active directory now if you want
to know more about Azor active directory
I suggest you click on the top right
corner and watch our video on the Azor
active directory this is just an
introduction so with this you can manage
user identities and you can make sure
the resources are kept safe with the
help of access policies most of these
are intelligence driven now one of the
main features is that you can have
access to your applications from any
location or device it helps increase
your efficiency and helps down cutting
cost when it comes to having a help desk
it can also help improve security and
can respond to Advanced threads in real
time next you have as your active
directory b2c it helps provide customer
identity and access management in the
cloud now protecting customer identity
is extremely important for an
organization and that's what a your ad
b2c does now it also enables the
application to be scaled to great
amounts even billions of customers next
we have the Azure security Center this
is basically like a command post with
which you get a complete view of the
security across users on your own
premises and Cloud workloads so with
this your given threat protection method
that adapts to situations and helps
reduce exposing you to threats it also
has rapid threat response and makes the
process of finding and fixing
vulnerabilities a whole lot easier next
up let's talk about monitoring and
Management Services so first let's have
a look at Azure advisor now Azure
advisor is basically a guide for the
best practices when it comes to Azure
now when you follow these it improves
performance security cost and increases
availability now it also learns from how
you use the services on your
configuration and usage pattern and the
adjustments that it suggests can be
implemented very quickly and easily next
we have Network Watcher now with this
you can monitor diagn know and
understand the working of your network
now you can monitor your network without
actually having to log in to your
virtual machine now you can also use
something known as network security flow
logs to understand the traffic pattern
how much traffic is coming towards you
how much you're giving and so much more
it also helps diagnose VPN problems that
you might have with detail logs and
finally you have the AO resource manager
now with this you can ensure that the
resources that you have are managed and
and deployed at a consistent rate now
this makes it extremely easy for you to
manage and visualize your resources that
are used in your applications or some
other requirements and you can control
who can access your resources as well as
perform actions on it and now let's have
a look at how we can use one of these
services to satisfy a particular
requirement so the friend asks that she
needs one last bit of help she wants her
friend's help to host a website on a z
and here's how we can do it so now we're
going to put put one of these Services
into action so this is the Azure
dashboard so from here we're going to
create a virtual machine within which we
are going to create a website a very
simple HTML website nonetheless so let's
get started so first what we're going to
do is create a resource a resource Group
so what a resource Group is is actually
a repository of all the resources like
virtual machines or storage that you're
going to use in your project so in this
we need a virtual machine so let's get
that created so first we'll name
it
demo e us and we'll create it now this
will take a few
seconds and that's it so now that that's
done we go on
ADD so we're going to be using a Windows
operating system so we'll just search
for virtual
machine we select this and
create okay so here we going to set up
we going to select the resource Group
the one just that we just created a
virtual machine
name
okay let's uh
storage
[Music]
name
passwords and then just Breeze through
the rest of it uh we can reduce the size
we need this
big and
create now that the validation is done
the next step is
to
create now this will take a few minutes
so we'll wait and as you can see here
the virtual machine has been created
we'll go to
Resource so here all we need to do is
connect and download the RDP file let's
see if we run this file and see what
happens now this error shows up in a
whole lot of systems that I've used so
there's a very easy way to troubleshoot
this problem so here's what you need to
do now so these are the problems as
remote access to the server is not
enabled the remote computer turned off
the remote computer is not available on
the network so what we're going to do is
go to networking
and add an inbound Port Rule now we're
trying to access a computer remotely
right so to remotely access the computer
we would need to add an inbound Port
rule so that's what we're going to do
right now so we can keep the source as
any port range as any and our
destination Port as 3389 if you've
noticed there we'd actually have used
the 3389 as the inbound port and then we
change the name as
3389 and this rule is added
now after this is done all we need to do
you can see here that we refresh the
page this would be
here a new rule has been added now so
we'll go to
overview and try to connect
again do the same thing
again and this time it worked so here
we'll input the name
and our
password and that's it now we just press
yes and there you go the system has
started now your virtual machine is
started now in a while the server
manager will pop up so there's some
things that we need to do so that we can
host the website so the first thing is
to create an inbound put so we'll turn
off the virtual machine for now come
back to that later first we'll go to a
resource
Group check the name of our
resource and then we look at all its
resources here so here we need to find
the network security group and add an
inbound security rule press add we take
any Source any Source Port range and
then we add Port 80 it is the one that
we going to use and we'll put the name
as Port
80 We'll add the security rule it will
take a few
seconds and that's that now it's allowed
now let's go back to our virtual
machine here you go and let's get it
started log in
again and there you have it it's on
again now we'll go to server manager so
we need to add roles and features so
most of this we can just run through
we'll leave them at the default values
same and here we need to add a web
server which is the IIs so we'll select
this we add the features next so we can
add the net 3.5 features as well
next
and we'll install
now now we'll wait for the installation
to
finish and now the installation is done
so now what we're going to see is if the
website can be reached we'll go to the
public address which is given here so
we've come back to our original system
click and you can see that the is Page
has been created now we need to work
more to create the HTML page here's what
we'll need to do to run our website so
right now what we getting is this the I
page now let's make it our own HTML page
a very simple HTML page from there on we
can create the website so we go back to
the what vir machine and then we go to C
drive so the is is located in a location
which is in C drive in it Pub and www
root so if you click on this actually
what you'll get is the page I showed you
earlier which is this one so now we'll
go to the server manager click on
tools and find the IIs
manager so we click on this
and sites now there's a default
website we can now add a new
one the site
name
demo we need a physical path we'll put
it inside the folder we just saw which
is right here C drive init Pub ww root
within which we'll create a new folder
for simply learn
demo we save it and Port 80 and okay now
this is assigned to another site so
we'll change that but we'll wait for
that
okay now for this we'll just change it
we click on this so since both of them
have the same port we'll change that go
here edit
binding we change this
to something
else okay and close so now both are
different and now we can start our
website it's already started
now now we'll start the website right
click this so manage website and
start and that's it now we will go to
the to the in Pub ww root and we have
simply learn demo so here we will create
the HTML website or the HTML the
document so index.
HTML
okay open
this it's a very simple website now so
we keep it save
it so here what we're going to do is
save
as an HTML file but for
all all
files we close this now to make sure
this is recognized as a HTML file it go
to
view
options here we'll hide extensions for
known file
types we just rename
this
and there you have it it's a HTML file
now let's go back to our original
computer and run this page and there you
have it now this is just the initial
version more work has to be done on it
let's talk about aure Services as I told
you aure provides services for a wide
range of domains now let's have a look
at some of these domains there's Ai and
machine learning compute containers
database identity management tools
networking Security Storage and so much
more now let's have a look at some of
the individual services within these
domains firstly you have aure virtual
machines with Az virtual machines what
you get is the opportunity to create
Windows or Linux virtual machines now
all of this is possible in a matter of
seconds with a large amount of
customization now let's have a look at
some of its features firstly you can
choose from a wide variety of virtual
machine options then you have a large
amount of optimization available to you
for example what size of operating
system do you want how much size do you
want allocated to it what version of the
system is it and so much more then it
provides low cost and permanent billing
now azer provides you per minute billing
which means that you're only charged for
how much time you use the service and
finally you have enhanced security and
protection for your virtual machines
next we have service fabric now with
service fabric you have a platform which
enables you to create microservices now
this also makes the process of
application life cycle management a
whole lot easier as a direct result you
you can create applications with a
faster time to Market it supports
Windows Linux on promises or other
clouds and it enables you to do a
tremendous amount of scaling up
depending on your requirement and
finally we have functions now with
functions you can build applications
with the help of serverless computing
here the users only pay for the amount
of resources that they've used you can
create applications in any language that
you want and the only thing you need to
worry about is the code of the
application everything other than that
that is the hardware requirements are
taken care of by Azure now let's have a
look at the networking Services firstly
we have the Azor CDN or the content
delivery network with Azure CDN what you
get is the ability to deliver your
content with reduced load times fast
responsiveness and less bandwidth now
CDN can be integrated with several other
AZ services so that the process can move
at a FAS rate it can handle heavy loads
and traffic spikes with ease it also
provides a robust security system now
with the content that's delivered you
can get Advanced analytic data with
which you can understand how customers
are using your content next we have
express route with express route you can
connect your on premisis network to aure
through a private Network Now by default
this lowers latency it increases the
emphasis on reliability and speed and it
can be of great use when you have to
transfer large amounts of data between
networks now another way this can be
useful is if it's used to add compute or
storage capacity to Data Centers next we
have Azure DNS domain name service or
Azure DNS can be used to host your
domains on Azure this provides High
availability and great performance it
provides fast responses to DNS queries
by taking advantage of Microsoft's
Global Network it also provides High
availability next we have virtual
Network Azo virtual Network allows the
AO resources to communicate with each
other or other on promise networks via
the Internet and all of this is
extremely secure now with this users can
create their own private Network for
communication it provides users with an
isolated and extremely secure
environment for their applications to
run now all of the traffic stays
entirely within the Azo Network and it
also allows users to design their own
networks next we have traffic manager
now with traffic manager you can route
incoming traffic to improve your
performance and availability now one
thing it provides is multiple failover
options so if a particular the situation
goes wrong there's always an option to
consider to salvage the situation it
helps reduce application runtime and
enables the distribution of user traffic
across multiple locations it also helps
the people who are using it to know
where the customers connecting from
across the world next we have load
balancer with this you have provided the
ability to instantly scale applications
at the same time providing High
availability and improv Network
performance for users applications it
can be integrated into virtual machine
and cloud services it provides highly
reliable applications it also allows
users to secure and integrate security
groups finally we have Azor VPN Gateway
now this allows users to connect their
entreprise networks to Azure using a s
side tosite VPN now this allows users to
connect their virtual machine to
anywhere in the world through a pointto
site VPN and also it's very easy to
manage and is highly available now let's
talk about the storage Services first we
have data Lake storage storage now with
this what you get is a scalable data
storage with an emphasis on cost
Effectiveness and scalability now it
comes of Maximum use when you've
integrated with other services so that
you can get analytics on how the data is
being used it is also integrated with
other services like the Azo blob storage
now it is also optimized for Big Data
analysis tools like Pache spark and
Hadoop next up we have blob storage now
blob storage provides a storage capacity
for data now depending on how often a
particular data is used it is classified
into different tiers now all the data
that is within the blob storage is
unstructured data now it has a way of
ensuring that the data Integrity is
maintained every time a particular
object is being changed or the data is
being accessed and it also helps improve
app performance and reduces bandwidth
consumption next we have q storage now
with this you have a message queuing
system for large workloads this allows
users to build flexible applications and
separate functions not to mention with
this you can be sure that your
individual components will not fail it
also makes sure that your application is
scalable Q storage provides Q monitoring
which helps ensure that the customer
demands are met then we have file
storage now with file storage you can
perform file sharing with the help of
the SMB protocol or the server message
block protocol now this data is
protected by SMB 3.0 and the https
protocol in this clay like we mentioned
in functions Azo takes care of all the
hardware needs and the operating system
deployments on its own it also improves
on premises performance and other
capabilities lastly we have table
storage with table storage you can
deploy semi structured data sets and an
osql key value store now this is used
for creating applications which have a
flexible data schema and also
considering how it has a very strong
consistency model it's mainly aimed for
Enterprises next let's have a look at
some web and mobile services first we
have the Azure search now with Azure
search you get a cloud search service
which is powered by artificial
intelligence with this you can develop
web applications as well as mobile
applications now one big Advantage is
that you don't have to set up or manage
your search indices as your takes care
of that and by extension it increases
your development speed the artificial
intelligence also will provide insights
and structured information that you can
use to improve the search and structured
information next we have logic apps now
with this you can create integration
Solutions which can connect applications
that are important to your business now
with this you can visually create
business processes and workflows you can
integrate SAS or software as a service
applications and Enterprise applications
and more importantly it allows you to
unlock data within the firewall and
securely connect to services next we
have web applications now with web apps
you can create deploy and scale web
applications according to business
requirements now it supports both
windows and Linux platforms and it helps
with continuous integration or
deployment abilities another very
important aspect of this is that the
data can be deployed and hosted across
multiple locations in the world and
finally we have mobile apps with mobile
apps you can create applications for iOS
Android and Windows platforms one
advantage is that it automatically
scales Up and Down based on your
requirements now in situations where you
have network issues offline data syncing
ensures that your applications work
anyway and you can create crossplatform
applications or native applications for
iOS Android and Windows next let's have
a look at some container services first
let's talk about ACS or Azo container
services it is also known as the azer
kubernets services as it's a fully
managed kubernets container
orchestration service now what this
means is that it eases the process of
container integration and deployment it
also can be used with other resources
from security like virtual networks
cryptographic keys and so much more to
ensure that your container is kept
secure next we have container instances
now this is similar to functions in a
way just that in this we're using
containers without having to manage
servers now applications can be
developed here without managing virtual
machines or learning new tools all that
is a Z's problem to take care of and it
enables building applications without
having to manage the infrastructure that
is all you need to worry about is
running the container next let's have a
look at some database Services first we
have the SQL database now with SQL
database what you get is a relational
Cloud database service now this means
that it helps accelerate your app
development and makes it easier for you
to maintain your application now SQL
database is also used extensively in
migrating workloads to the cloud and
hence saves time and cost it also helps
improve your performance by integrating
machine learning and Adaptive
Technologies into your database next we
have Azure Cosmos DB now this is a
globally distributed multimodel database
service now what this means is that with
this you can create application with
support nosql it provides a high-grade
security system has high availability
and low latency now this is usually used
in situations where you have a diverse
and highly unpredictable workload now
let's have a look at some security and
identity Services firstly we have the
Azure active directory now if you want
to know more about Azure active
directory I suggest you click on the top
right corner and watch our video on the
Azure active directory this is just an
introduction so with this you can manage
user identities and you can make sure
the resources are kept safe with the
help of access policies most of these
are intelligence driven now one of the
main features is that you can have
access to your applications from any
location or device it helps increase
your efficiency and helps down cutting
costs when it comes to having a help
desk it can also help improve security
and can respond to Advanced threats in
real time next you have a your active
directory b2c it helps provide customer
identity and access management in the
cloud now protecting customer identity
is extremely important for an
organization and that's what as your ad
b2c does now it also enables the
application to be scaled to great
amounts even billions of customers next
we have the Azure security Center this
is basically like a command post with
which you get a complete view of the
security across users on your own
premises and Cloud workloads so with
this you're given threat protection
method that adapts to situations and
helps reduce exposing you to threats it
also has rapid threat response and makes
the process of finding and fixing
vulnerabilities a whole lot easier next
up let's talk about monitoring and
management services so first let's have
a look at Azure advisor now Azure
advisor is basically a guide for the
best practices when it comes to Azure
now when you follow these it improves
performance security cost and increases
availability now it also learns from how
you use the services on your
configuration and usage pattern and the
adjustments that it suggests can be
implemented very quickly and easily next
we have Network Watcher now with this
you can monitor diagnose and understand
the working of of your network now you
can monitor your network without
actually having to log in to your
virtual machine now you can also use
something known as network security flow
logs to understand the traffic pattern
how much traffic is coming towards you
how much you're giving and so much more
it also helps diagnose VPN problems that
you might have with detail logs and
finally you have the AZ resource manager
now with this you can ensure that the
resources that you have are managed and
deployed at a consistent rate now this
makes it extremely easy for you to
manage and visualize your resources that
are used in your applications or some
other requirements and you can control
who can access your resources as well as
perform actions on it machine learning's
major purpose is to train models and
anticipate outcomes that may be used by
applications scripts are used in Azure
machine learning to train models using
machine learning Frameworks that enable
us to quickly operationalize d diverse
machine learning jobs and iterative
processes while leveraging Microsoft
azure's massive computational power but
knowing this much is not enough and
therefore here we are so hello everyone
welcome to this new video of Simply
learn on Azure machine learning in this
video we'll go through Azure machine
learning in detail including it
capabilities the Azure ecosystem that
supports machine learning and the
various ways we train and build models
starting
with what is azure machine learning
followed by who is machine learning for
then we will look into its
infrastructure Readiness and
security then we will dive into machine
learning project workflow following that
we will understand mlops devops for
machine learning and at last we will
explore the Azure machine Learning
Studio after that we will have a demo
to so without doing any further delay
let's start with the
video so what is aure machine learning
Azure machine learning is a Cloud
solution that helps you speed up and
manage your machine learning projects it
can be used by Machine learning
Specialists data scientists and
engineers in the daily workflows models
are trained and deployed and mlops are
managed you can use an open open source
platform like pytorch tensorflow or S
kit learn to build a model or use one
created in asure machine learning model
monitoring retraining and redeployment
are all made easier using these
tools but this brings us to a question
that who exactly machine learning is
for so individuals and teams deploying
mlops inside their company can use Azure
machine learning to move machine
learning models into production in a
safe and auditable
environment data scientists and machine
learning experts will find tools to help
them speed up and automate their daily
task tools for embeding models into
applications or services will be
available to application
developers platform developers will find
a strong set of tools for constructing
Advanced ml technology underpinned by
resilient is as your resource manager
apis now that we know the basics of
azure ml let's have a look at its
infrastructure Readiness and
security so Azure machine learning is an
Azure Cloud platform that adds security
to machine learning projects so
Integrations for security include the
following network security groups in AIA
virtual networks aure key is a V where
you may store security Secrets like
storage account access
details and set up an Azure container
registry behind a
vet so now let's dive down deep and
explore its project
workflow models are usually created as
part of project with a specific goal and
objective multiple people are usually
involved in these projects iterative
development is used while experimenting
with data algorithms and models now
coming to to the Project Life
Cycle while the project lifespan will
differ dep depending on the project it
will typically look like this a work
space organizes a project and facilitate
collaboration among multiple users who
are all working toward the same
goal users in a workspace May easily
share the result of the experiments
through the studio user interface or
they can use version assets for jobs
like environments and storage
references so users work can be
automated in a machine learning Pipeline
and activated on a timetable or https
request when a project is ready for
operation therefore models can be
deployed to the manage
interfering solution in real time or
batch abstracting away the
infrastructure management that is
traditionally necessary for model
deployment now let's proceed further and
understand the concept of mlops that is
devops for machine
learning mlops or devops for machine
learning is a process for generating
models for production use if not
reproducible the lifetime of a model
from training to deployment must be
auditable mlops or machine learning
operations is based on devops principles
and methods to improve workflow
efficiency continuous integration
delivery and deployment for example
these ideas are applied to the machine
learning process by mlops with the
purpose of experimentation and model
deployment can be done more quickly and
quality assurance and interent lineage
tracking are more efficient ways to put
models into
production now let's explore what what
is azure ml
studio so Azure machine Learning Studio
is an online service that includes low
code and no code alternatives for
project development and asset management
in Azure machine
learning basically it is a workspace
where you can create build train the
machine learning models for an inclusive
data science platform the studio
integrates no code and no Co code first
experience
so now that we have covered all the
important concepts of azure machine
learning let's have a demo for a better
understanding of how machine learning is
used in
Azure so let's start with the Demo First
you need to browse the link studio. aure
ml.net and here you need to log in with
your Azure account so once you have
logged in you will be led to a new
window this is the new window here you
can see a few options
so let's start uh and see one by one
what these options are so the first one
is projects basically this gives you a
list of all the experiments that you
have already worked on so here you can
see we haven't worked on any experiment
yet then comes uh
experiment experiments are all the
programs and codes that you have worked
on to create it or deploy a model that
you have just created for an experiment
so so as I said we haven't created any
experiment yet so the list is null over
here when you click on samples you can
see a
few sample experiments provided to you
by Ash
your portal by
default and following that we have web
services so we all know since asure is a
cloud computing platform so all the data
gathered from our experiments needs to
be uploaded to the cloud Cloud so web
services gives you a list of all the
experiments that you have in the cloud
so you can access them from anywhere so
uh when you create an experiment and
work on it when you add it to the cloud
that data is stored
here so then comes data
sets it gives you all the data sets you
have in your Azure portal when you click
on the samples
option again you can see all the data
sets provided to you by default in your
asop
portal then comes train
models so while working on a experiment
you will come across a point where you
need to train your
model so basically this gives you a list
of all the models that you have trained
in your experiments or Azure
programs and in the last come settings
any changes that you want to make to
your workspace is done under settings
here you can see see uh this is your
workspace name workspace description
which is by default and all the details
is provided here only so whatever
changes you want to make to your
workspace you'll be doing this over
here so now let's start with a demo so
down below you can see the add or new
Option here so click on it and then you
can see there are a few way uh templates
provided by you provided to you by asure
itself so we'll click on blank
experiment once you click on the blank
experiments uh you'll be guided to a new
experiment window so this is the new
window and this window is divided into
three parts these are the
components where you will plan your
model this is the canvas to design your
model and then the properties of the
model
in the component section you can see
samples already present there so you can
select any one of them according to your
requirement so here when I'm typing
samples uh I'll work on airport codes
data sets so I just need to drag this
option over
here but before starting uh with our
experiment let's change the name so here
I'm changing it to
airport
codes demo
model so now you can see the name of the
experiment is
changed now when you click on it and uh
select
visualize just a
second
you can see the number of rows and
columns provided to it the datas which
is required for its data set to be
created and for its model to be
created so the four rows four columns
are airport ID city state and
name now uh we will move towards the
part where we Define field we need to
make a predictions score so type columns
in the
search bar
uh under manipulation
section you can see there are multiple
options provided to you so here we will
select select columns and data
sets as we are working on data
sets now now connect your data set with
this
option so you can see a red alert over
here
so when you click on
it you can see it is asking for values
in your data set so to add values click
on the launch column selector under
properties
section
so once you click on it here you need to
select all the options needed for
required values so for my experiment
model I need all these data sets so I'll
add all of these and then click on the
save
option so let me just add
this see now now I have
saved all the values I need in our in my
data set so now uh you can see the alert
is gone so now we have the data sets
that we want to work on so let's look
for an appropriate algorithm for it so
while looking into the classification
algorithm we know that
our
so here you can see it under
classification model we have these
options so we know that a Target value
is divided into two classifications so
the algorithm we will be using is uh two
class so we will be using two class
booster decision
tree because it calculates the accuracy
for every node and once the calculated
accuracy is more than are required
accuracy then only it moves to the next
node so basically this gives you a
prediction value close to the accurate
value of the model so we will just drag
this option over
here so now the next step we have is to
train our model so we just need to type
train over
here
and select train model
option
yeah
so just drag it to the canvas now
connect the two booster decision tree to
the train
model now you can again see the red
alert for a required data as it doesn't
have any data to work on so our next
step is to split the
data so we'll type
split and drag the split data option on
our
canvas as you can see this is also
saying uh it needs an input Port data
set so we'll connect a data set with it
so that it is it is provided with the
data so when you click on it you can see
it is asking for uh split
percentage so you split the data into
training and testing where 80% goes to
training and 20% to testing so we will
mention 0.08 over
here and
uh so now we will just connect the 80%
data to the train model as we said the
80% goes for
training but you can still see the alert
in the train model because it is not
aware of the column it needs to train on
so we will click
on uh launch column
selector
now you just need to select all the
columns you need to work on so I'm
selecting the airport ID
number now you can see uh once I save it
that the alert is
gone now our next step is to find the
score of a model so let's type
score in our search
bar
and drag the score model over here let
me just reduce the size of the canvas
yeah so we will just connect our train
model to the score
model
so again you will see the Red Alert as
it doesn't know the data it needs to
test on so for that we will connect the
remaining testing data and the split
data option to
the score
model now you can see the allot option
is
gone now coming to the final step that
is evaluation of the model so let's type
evaluation and here you can see the
evaluate model option we just need to
drag it to the
canvas
yeah so
let's connect it with our score
model now your model for the airport
code data set is complete so this is the
whole model now you need to save the
model and then click on run
option so here I've have saved it and uh
you can see it's
running
you can see the model running and going
through every node as you can see the
green
Mark as it's verifying through every
node so once it's done click on evaluate
model and uh then click on
visualize now you can see the accuracy
is
uh
98 here you can see the accuracy is 98
which is almost the prediction value now
you can see the positive and negative
labels as
well
so this whole data is known as confusion
Matrix now for the values close to the
pos positive label it gives me the
number of true
predictions that uh the number of data
I'll provide H uh it will it shows that
72 predictions will be right and one
will be
wrong now let's go back and uh run this
model over the web
so by clicking on uh setup web service
we will click on predictive web
service now we will just uh connect web
service input to the score
model so that once the program is
uploaded to the Cloud it is directly
connected to the score model and gives
us the
output so now you need to save
this and
run this will execute the entire model
now all uh we are left with is deploying
the
module
now we just need to click on deploy web
service so then you will see you will be
taken to a new
window here you can uh see the response
page where it's showing test option you
need to click on
it so here you can see a new window has
popped up so you just need to mention
the details like for City I am
mentioning
Bangalore first dat I'm mentioning
kataka and name of the airport
is
K
International
Airport and I just need to save this
data so now down below you can see it
gives me predictive
values and this is the airport
ID for my mentioned details so the
accuracy of this ID will be 0.98 which
is
98% which is almost accurate to the
100% so this was our experiment and this
is how we can use ml in Asher in this
video I will take you through what is
ashure active
directory followed by what is the
difference between Windows 8 and Ash
your ad then we will look into the
services audience I.E who uses these
services and at last we will have a
quick demo of asure active directory so
let's get started with the
video first what is azure active
directory but before getting into the
definition of azure ad let's have a real
life example of asure ready to
understand it in a better
way there are a lot of pre-created
applications that you can offer user
access to using Azure ad so Netflix is
one of them so here's the scenario you
want to share a Netflix account with a
dozen people from your organization
giving your Netflix username and
password to everyone isn't safe so how
do you give them
access here enters asure
ad the Netflix application is available
in the aszure ad gallery and can be
added to your aure ad
tenant this adds the application to your
tency and allows you to save your
Netflix credentials in the secured
credential store so that users can be
assigned to
it the only people who have access are
the ones you give it to unless they have
their own account you're essentially
building a company white password Vault
then assigning people to the systems
they require access to so they can log
in without knowing the username and
password for those systems all they need
is the Azure ad account or password and
Azure ad will handle the
rest so saying in technical terms asure
active directory is a cloud-based
identity and access management service
from Microsoft that allows your
employees to sign in and
access resources such as Microsoft 365
the Azure portal and thousands of other
SAS
apps and internal resources such as apps
on your company's infranet and network
as well as any Cloud apps built by a
company asure ad is required for signin
and identity protection in Microsoft
online business services such as
Microsoft 365 and Azure if you sign up
for any Microsoft online business you'll
be given access to Azure ad which
includes all of the free
services but what makes Azure ad so
different from Windows ad8 that it has
become more popular among people from
technical
firm what is Windows
ad active directory saves information
about Network objects and make it easier
for administrator and users to find and
use their
information it organizes directory
information logically and hierarchically
using a structured data
store but Supreme drawback is its
layers so let's have a look at its
layers and its
functioning first is
adds Windows active directory domain
Services active directory domain
Services is an example of a directory
service that provides mechanisms for
storing directory data and making it
available to network users and
administrators second is ADF
active directory Federation Services
Federated identity and access management
is made possible by active directory
Federation service with security shares
digital identity and entitlements right
across security and corporate boundaries
to provide customers partners and
suppliers with a streamline user
experience while accessing an
organization's web- based
applications adfs extends the ability to
employ single sign on capability except
accessible within a single security or
Enterprise boundary to internet facing
apps third is adms active directory
right Management Services Microsoft's
active directory Rights Management
Services Safeguard sensitive documents
and emails unlike traditional security
methods like firewalls and ACLS adms
encryption and protection remain
constant regardless of where a file goes
or how it is transferred
but Azure active directory actually
combine these layers and make the whole
process more easier and hassle-free
Azure ad combines these layers into two
layers wad Windows Active Azure
directory and windows Azure Access
Control
service Windows Active Azure directory
combines all the problems revolving
around identification
management and windows Azure Access
Control ser service takes care of
federating all the services of an
organization so let's have an example
when an employee join the premises of an
organization the administrator guides
them towards signing to particular
Services they use and then give access
to it and the employees can access these
Services through the credentials like
username and
password now that we know what is azure
active directory and how it functions
from adds let's have a look at the
service audience of azure active
directory Azure ad is majorly intended
to R admins app developers and online
subscribers for it admins you can use as
your ad as an IT administrator to limit
access to your apps and app resources
based on your business needs when
accessing critical organizational
resources for example you can utilize as
your ad to enforce multiactor
authentication finally asure active
directory provides you with strong
features to help you protect users
identities and credentials while also
meeting your access governance
requirements as an app developer you may
utilize asure ad to add single sign on
to your app using a standard based
method allowing it to function with the
users's existing
credentials also asure ad
has apis that may be used to create
customized app experiences based on
existing organizational
data for online
subscribers you're already using aszure
ad as a subscriber each tenant of
Microsoft 365 Office 365 Azure and
dynamic CRM online is an Azure ad tenant
by default you may begin managing access
to your connected clouds apps right
away so now that we know the basic
concept of azure ad let's have a quick
demo of
it so the first thing we need to do is
login in our Azure ID
account and then go to Azure active
directory
sector here you will see add option
where you can add a user group
Enterprise application app registration
according to your choice
and below that you can search for any
inant like for user or for any group so
right now it doesn't belongs to any
group or there is no user with this
name here you will get basic information
like their name what is their ID what is
the license which groups they
belong and what devices they use you can
Al have an access to their password as
well so if you are interested in
becoming an Azure certified professional
then consider simply learn Azure Cloud
architect Masters program Azure Cloud
architect Masters program will help you
master the Azure infrastructure by
understanding Azure Cloud architect
Technology Solutions implementing
workloads and Security in Azure creating
and deploying apps in Azure and securing
data in AO now who should take this
program fresher graduates who are intent
on taking the plunge into the job market
second professionals with less than 2
years of experience who are working in
either technical or non-technical job
rules and want to shift to the cloud so
what are you waiting for enroll now get
certified and get ahead and today we're
going to talk about another important a
your service a your data Factory now why
should you be interested in data Factory
now let's consider a scenario so here we
have two colleagues having a
conversation with each other and they
say that the data that they're
generating from their applications of
products is increasing exponentially now
considering that this data is coming
from a number of different products
it'll be a bit of a task to analyze and
store all of this data so he wonders how
they're going to manage that his friend
suggests that they use az's data Factory
now what does azzo's data Factory
actually do first it stores data with
the help of the data leak storage now
any kind of data can be stored in the
data Lake storage then you can analyze
the data you can transform the data with
the help of pipelines and you can
publish the organized data you can
visualize the data with third party
applications like Apache spark or Hadoop
as well now what exactly is data Factory
so now let's have a look at what exactly
is data Factory now data Factory falls
under the identity domain of services in
the Azo catalog and is a cloud-based
integration service basically what it
does is it works on your data it stores
your data it orchestrates and automates
the movement or transformation of data
it works Works heavily on the data that
you store now let's see how it actually
works or how the flow of its processes
are firstly we have the input data set
which is nothing but the data that you
have within your data store the one that
you need processed then you pass this
data through a pipeline now what does a
pipeline do a pipeline basically
performs an operation on the data that
transforms it which could be anything
from just data movement or some data
transformation now data transformation
is possible with the help of usql some
stored procedures or Hy now after this
is done you get an output data set now
this output data set will contain data
that is in a structured form because
it's already been transformed and made
structured in the pipeline stage then it
is given into Link services like aure
data Lake block storage or SQL now what
it does is these store information that
is very important when it comes to
connecting to an external Source now
this is you know if you wanted an
example you know how in an SQL Server
you need to mention the source do and
destination of your data now for example
consider an SQL Server so you need a
connection string so that you can
connect to an external device you need
to mention the stores and the
destination of your data this is how the
Link services work and finally you need
a Gateway now a Gateway basically
connects your on promises data to the
cloud so you do need a client installed
on your on promises system so that you
can connect to the Azure cloud and
finally you have the cloud here what
happens is your data can be analyzed or
visualized with a number of different
analytical softwares like Apache spark R
Hadoop and so on so all this time I've
been mentioning that data lake is a very
important part when it comes to a your
data Factory's proper functioning so now
let's talk about what exactly is data
Lake now data lake is a data storage or
a file system which is highly scalable
and distributed it is located in the
cloud and works with multiple analytics
Frameworks which is external framework
like Hadoop Apache and so on so now
let's have a look at it so first you
have your output data set which is data
from the mobile video web social media
so much more it is sent into the Azure
data Lake store and then it is provided
two external Frameworks like our Pache
and Spark so that they can be worked on
now there are two main Concepts when it
comes to data Lake storage so one of
them is storage and the other one is
analytics now storage is of unlimited
size it can be petabytes terabytes
gigabytes and so much more it stores a
wide variety of data it could be
unstructured or structured data and it
can store really large files and another
concept when it comes to data L is
analytics now how it works now here are
two examples of how analytics works when
it comes to data Lake now when it comes
to analytics you can monitor and
diagnose realtime data for example data
that you're getting from vehicles or
buildings these can be used to optimize
how they work respond to certain events
or generate alerts in case something
goes wrong then you can also identify
fraudulent transactions on your credit
card or you can identify the correct the
geographical position of your card
perhaps monitor how many transactions
have been taking place on that card and
so on so now we're going to have a look
at how we can use the Azo data Factory
to move data from an SQL database to a
blob storage on the cloud so here's what
we're going to do so first off to make a
database what you're going to need a
software known as SSN Ms so you can find
it on Google it's called you just need
to Google it SS SMS the first link you
can take here and there you have it so
you just need to click here and download
the file so we I've already downloaded
the file so basically this is used to
create a database which we'll be
transferring to The Blob storage so this
will take about depending on your
computer speed pretty long or little to
no time I've already downloaded it the
process is very simple just directly go
on saying yes yes and finally once the
installation is done here's what we we
going to do we should go into the
dashboard of Microsoft asure we need to
create a data warehouse so we'll go into
all the sources Creator Source go to
database and select SQL data warehouse
there we have it now it's very important
that you remember the names of the
service of everything that you're going
to write here because each of these
become very important later on so I've
already set up a possible set of
names YouTube it's free to F the source
is already
created blank database the server we
need to create a new one
so you'll name it as YouTube
server
YouTube admin as the server admin login
the password
as all right the location does not
matter okay that's done now here the
server is done and here we need to
change how much you want the lowest I
mean how much computation you want how
much the workload how important your
workload is so we'll put it at the
lowest since we don't require much we'll
apply the rest is normal and
create so now we creating an SQL data
warehouse so we'll wait so now the
deployment is done so we'll go to the
notification and and go to the resource
here now this is done so we'll go to the
s SMS which I've already opened here and
then go here and copy this paste it here
SQL authentication login which details
we have already stored here which is
admin YouTube admin and the password
which is also given
there right go to options we go to the
database name which is YouTube
everything else is there you need to
change it to
tcpip and connect
we sign
in we'll add the
password and we're going to sign in
now
right so now that that's completed you
can see that this is what will pop up so
this is the name of the server we've
given as you saw earlier we go to
databases and here you have the YouTube
database that we just created right
click this and add a new query I already
have a code for this program it's a very
simple program so copying and pasting
this if you need the code for this
program let us know in the comments
below it's very simple what we're doing
is creating a table called demo tab with
first name clarkent and last name is
Bruce way and the table that's created
will have these two rows so now we're
going to execute this there you have it
two rows have been affected so now let's
have a look at our
table
what execute this line and there you go
the table's here so now that this is
done we going back into
aure back and we need to create a
storage account so that's where the
storage where the blob storage is going
to happen so we're going to storage
accounts and click on ADD so here it's a
free trial Resource Group is YouTube
storage account name
is please
store that's all okay here performance
is standard general purpose can do
locally since we don't need it to be
very reliable at least for this one
Advance just F View and create that's
done and we create now we'll wait for
the deployment to
finish and that's it the deployment is
done so we'll go to the
resource and go to blobs so this is
where the storage is happening we need
to create create a
blob simply
blob which does not exist and
okay it has been created now for the
next bit we need to create the data
Factory now so we go to all services
search for data
Factory we press
add so here
we'll
free trial use existing which we have
YouTube USS and create so now we've
created a new data Factory now we'll
wait while it's being deployed so now
it's created so we'll go here and here
we click on copy data and this opens
up we'll name
it our description run once now
now on now
okay right so we press next so we need
to connect to a data source so so what
you need to do is Select as as your SQL
data warehouse so one second go to
previous here we select as your SQL data
warehouse go here search
for
Source your subscription free trial Here
YouTube server and the database is
YouTube you also need to provide your
username and password I've saved it
here YouTube
[Music]
admin
right okay now we can select the table
which is demo tab
next next and now for our destination so
where are we going to connect this to
we're going to Z blob storage next
destination J subscription free trial
and simply
store now we need to name
our name our storage path next all of
this can be passed on so here's what
we're doing we copying whatever is
inside this to the Azure blob storage
that's what's happening right now
all of that is
set
and next it's validating and we'll wait
now it's registering connections
creating database and in the end it's
creating a
pipeline so you can monitor the pipeline
from here if you feel like
it now here's what we're going to find
so here's the here's a visual
representation of what's
happening it's being copied into the
blob storage let's have a look if it's
actually worked out we go to our
database we'll go into storage accounts
simply
store go to
blobs you created a new
one and there you have it so based on
the container that you've named there
it's created a new one here so actually
I earlier created the name called simply
blob but as you can see here as long as
you name a container it'll create a
folder inside which you will find your
particular thing that you copied and
that's it you've copied data similarly
you can do a number of multiple
operations on this container on the on
the pipeline you just created with the
data Factory and that's that today we
are going to learn about the azer
virtual machine so without further Ado
let's get started before getting in
depth let me tell you what's in store
for today first I'll be talking a little
about AZ next I'll start off by
explaining the Azo virtual machine then
I'll be focusing on few benefits of Azo
virtual machine moving forward I'll be
going in depth with the Azo virtual
machine components and finally we will
be looking into a demo on Azo virtual
machine all of us may have heard of Azo
at one point of time but what is Azia
let me explain Azia is a cloud service
created by Microsoft for building
testing and managing applications and
many services through the Microsoft data
centers the Azure host web applications
or the internet with the help of these
data centers Azia is very flexible it
gives an option to have the
functionality as required you can pay as
you consume switch to Azo and
accommodate the business fluctuations
there's no need to worry about the
infrastructure all the time Azo is very
reliable and has 24/7 tech support a
your offers pay as you go pricing and
hence it is is very cost- effective
staying online all the time ensures
customers or users trust aure supports
backup and Disaster Recovery tools now
we know what Azor is and its key
benefits let's now move on to Azor
virtual machine before that let's
consider a scenario Rachel had to host
10 virtual machines at once for a
project there was an issue when her
computer RAM was not compatible with the
instances the computer RAM was only 8GB
and the instances that required were
10gb then she says I wish there is a
service that's coste effective and also
provides extra RAM memory one of her
colleague heard this and he comes up
with an idea he says can we use Azo
virtual machine it has a pay as you go
pricing and has disc for storage you can
pay for what you use and create any
number of instances with high storage
capacity also if any technical
difficulty arises you can easily
retrieve the files through the backup
server so now she's happy and she wants
to know more about Azo wasal machine
Azo virtual machine is one of the wide
range of services that Azia offers to
create your instance a virtual machine
is a computer file typically called an
image which behaves like an actual
computer it runs in a window giving the
user the same experience on a virtual
machine as they have on the host
operating system itself multiple virtual
machines can run simultaneously on the
same physical computer each virtual
machine provides its own Hardware like
CPUs memories and other devices a your
virtual machine offers a high range of
flexibility and it maintains the
physical Hardware that runs on it let me
explain some of the benefits of Azo
virtual machine first we have easy
development and test AO virtual machine
has a quick and easy way to configure
the computer that is required to code
and test an application next agility and
scale Azo virtual machine is agile and
the ability to clone and spin up
multiple instances of the same virtual
machine allows us to scale services and
applications rapidly efficiently and
well very cost effectively a your
virtual machine provides enhanced
performance demands for applications can
fluctuate so you pay for the virtual
machines you need and shut down the
unnecessary ones to save the cost AO
virtual machines provide extended Data
Center and can be easily connected to an
organization's Network it is easy to set
up your redundant infrastructure on AZ
and azer provides a full Disaster
Recovery site at a fraction of the cost
furthermore let me explain Azia virtual
machine components in details virtual
machine comes under the compute domain
off AIO it also offers various services
like availability sets snapshots diss
images and many other services like
hosts watching machine can be clubbed
with other services like disk images
availability sets hosts and many more so
the first component and the most
important component is the operating
system the operating system creates
connections to the remote desktop
session host there are many operating
systems available like Ubuntu Red Hat
Linux Windows Server sent OS you can
also set the operating dis size so that
the memory is not wasted the next
component is diss a your virtual
machines use attached virtual hard diss
for storage there are two types of
virtual hard dis first is an image it is
a template for creation of new Azo
virtual machine then we have discs it is
a bootable virtual hard disk all durable
discs are backed up by Page blobs in
Azia storage therefore the diss inherit
the benefit of blob storage High
availability durability and many more
the discs are mounted as drives on the
VM the next component is virtual Network
many components operate the virtual
machines in a scalable and secure manner
virtual networks could include equipment
such as separate Network spaces for
internet facing and backend servers load
balancers firewalls and more many of
these components are deployed into an
Azo virtual Network Azo virtual Network
provides many features such as subnet IP
address load balancer and network
security group another important
component of a virtual machine is
availability sets if in case there's a
slight chance there could be a failure
in physical servers then these come into
picture so in case of such failure the
azer platform will migrate the failed
virtual machine to a healthy host to
reconstitute the VM it is highly
recommended to deploy at least two
instances of the virtual machine and
virtual machines placed on an
availability set perform identical set
of functionalities
now that we know what Azia virtual
machine is let's look into the demo in
this Demo First we are going to create a
virtual machine connect it and then
create a web server and modify the web
server and finally launch the web
application so let's go ahead into the
demo now so the first step is to log
into Microsoft Azure with your
credentials now let's click on Virtual
machines and create a new
one so I can put
add
and you can use the subscription you
want either pay as you go pricing or
free Tio Resource Group will create a
new one that is
payroll
one okay virtual machine we can create
I'm going to use VM web
001 and then region I'll be using Okay
East
us then image I'll be using Windows
Server R2 Data Center
enter size I'll be using B1
Ms
select
username and then password of your
choice
and then I'm going to allow selected
ports and choose RDP
3389 and
next so OS step I'll be using standard
HGD and then yeah
next so I can see a default virtual
Network and a default submit and public
IP as well as
default then
next
you can allow for auto shutdown but
again it's entirely your
choice I'm going to select an extension
to install and I'm going to install
Microsoft
antimalware create
okay I'm going to create a few tags now
let's go ahead with
it
so I've created Five tags now review
plus
create okay so everything seems good
let's create
now so the deployment is going to take a
few minutes let's wait for
it
okay so that's done now let's go to
watching machine and see our watching
machine okay so it's been
deployed now let's get into the watchin
machine and copy the IP
address then hit Windows plus
r and open
mstsc
and paste the IP address and
connect
let's use a different account you have
to use the administrator account that
we've created before with the same
password click
okay now remote desktop session host
opens the next step is to click on
server manager
and add rules and
features click on
next select Ro based of feature based
installation and click on
next then select the watching machine
you've created and next and then we are
going to
select web server I
next
sorry
next okay so it's already installed my
computer but you have to install this
then let's close
this and open Internet
Explorer let's type in
HTTP Local
Host yeah so now we can see the default
browser opening let's minimize
this and let's try it
here here you have just put the IP
address think there's an
issue okay so let's add an inbone Port
networking select networking and add INB
port
let's move
48 and
add okay so it's added now let's go and
refresh
it now we can see the default web
browser opening so the next step is to
modify the web browser let's go ahead
with that go back to your remote session
host let's go file
explorer so certain folders are created
in the C drive let's open that it would
be under IET
Pub so this is where the default brow is
coming from now let's make a new textt
document
open that and
put
hello
welcome to this
demo by Sy
la
save
it close it let's rename this
as
index.
HT
sorry
M so this is a text document so we need
to change
that
okay let's remove
this okay that's
done now let's go back to our Internet
Explorer and hit
F5 let's refresh
this let's try now okay so
let's
yeah so it's done now let's go back to
the previous browser and try let's
refresh so today's uh topic is azure
virtual Network tutorial let's look into
what's in it for you so we would be
covering why is azure virtual Network
important what is azure virtual network
is benefits of using the Azure virtual
Network components of aure virtual
Network that includes the subnet routing
Network Security Group why these
components are required to be created in
the virtual Network and how to launch an
instance uh within the Azure vnet or the
virtual Network and then we will be
seeing one demo in which we'll create
Azure virtual Network subnets and
network security groups so first of all
let's look into why is azure virtual
Network
important so why Azure virtual network
is required so somewhere far away at an
office a company was struggling with few
challenges the company got a bigger
projects which lead to the following
challenges that includes poor network
connectivity timec consuming process in
building Network topologies could not
divert Network traffic to its
destination on time so these were a
couple of challenges the company was
facing so the employees thought that
what could be the possible solution to
these
challenges and then we require the Azure
virtual Network in that case so first of
all let's understand what is azure
virtual network is an Azure vet or a
virtual Network represents your network
or environment to run VMS and
applications in the
cloud when it is created the services
and virtual machines within the network
interact securely with each over the
Internet so virtual Network you can
consider it as a virtual Cloud which is
basically kind of a cloud space
virtually assigned to the users or or to
the organization which they can
dedicatedly use for their purpose so for
example if you have to create some uh
instances or virtual machines onto the
Azure cloud and you want to connect it
with the on-prem servers for example uh
then you might require the virtual
Network in that case let's assume that
those instances that are created in the
virtual Network require the range of IP
addresses that you want to allocate to
them and that is something you can
customize using the Azure virtual
Network how do you want that the traffic
should should be routed to your
instances in the virtual Network how the
firewall Securities should be applied
everything the end user can control in
the virtual Network so it seems like
that you are working in your own data
center ideally you would be working onto
the Azure Cloud using the virtual
Network now what are the advantages of
using the Azure virtual Network so a
couple of them are it provides an
isolated environment for your
application so as I said that it feels
like it seems like that you are working
in your on Prim environment that means
within your data center but ideally it
is a virtual space that is allocated to
you which is a kind of an isolated
environment uh that is specifically
designed for your task and the
activities a generally a subnet in a vet
can access the public internet by
default so we create a subnet inside the
virtual Network which can access the
public internet so there is a public
network connectivity that is inable
abled in the virtual net so that a
subnet which will be created in the vnet
can be
accessed traffic can be easily filtered
from different resources so you can have
some uh control lists defined you can
have some security groups created and
how do you want to allow the traffic
onto the servers or the application that
is something which you can control it is
a highly secure network and the security
groups and the policies are basically
implemented by the end user so you can
design how the security should be
implemented High network connectivity so
you have a higher bandwidth as compared
to the normal internet connection you
might be having in the data center
compared to that you use the Azure
Network only which gives you the higher
network connectivity it builds
sophisticated Network topologies in a
simple Manner and which is easily
manageable as well as there are less
troubleshooting issues that we would
encounter now what are the components of
azure virtual Network one of them is the
subnets then you have
routing then you have network security
groups now what do we mean by
subnets the subnet is one of the major
or a prime important component in the
virtual Network so what you have to do
is first obviously you would be creating
a virtual Network inside that you can
create the subnets subnets you can
consider it a logical partitioning or
virtual partitioning inside the virtual
Network subnet lets user segment the
virtual Network into one or more subn
networks for example let's assume that
you're working in an organization and in
the organization there are different
departments for every Department there
should be some set of IP addresses that
you want to allocate to the machines
that the employees are using or all the
department should be isolated that means
means they should have their own network
IDs and the network addresses allocated
to their machines and in that case what
you would do is you would create the
subnets and the subnet IDs that would be
allocated to those departments these sub
networks can be separated logically and
each subnet consist of a server so what
you do is when you create a subnet you
can uh you can create a server or an
instance inside that subnet and how do
you want to give an access to that
instance depends on criteria or the
requirement
hence a subnet can further be divided
into two parts one as the public subnet
and the other one as the private subnet
these are the naming conventions of the
subnet then how do you want to give the
internet connectivity depends on how the
public subnet should be interacting with
the internet and for the private subnet
as the name suggests that the internet
is blocked so that means it is
completely isolated in the virtual
Network the private instances though if
you want that any instance created in
the private subnet should have the
internet connectivity or an access you
can primarily go with the N gateways in
that case which is a network address
translation or kind of a translator
which converts the private to public and
visce Versa and that would actually
enable the internet connectivity to your
subnets then in the public instances
they can directly access the instance as
the name suggest public instances that
public subnets that means they have the
direct internet connectivity next
component is routing
and the routing is primarily a routing
rules you can say that are applied and
those are actually applied to the
routers only so since on the cloud we
cannot have a direct router access and
hence using the routing as a component
we can Define some routing rules which
are directly applied to the router in
the
infrastructure it delivers the data by
choosing a suitable path from source to
destination for each subnet aure virtual
Network automatically routes traffic and
creates a route table when you create a
virtual Network automatically a route
table is created and that basically is
required to Route the traffic and that
can be used by every subnet that doesn't
mean that you only have to create a
single route table in the virtual
Network you can have multiple route
tables also created which can be
associated with different subnets as
well then you have the network security
groups uh it is kind of a firewall that
protects the virtual machine by limiting
the network
traffic it restricts inbound and
outbound Network traffic depending upon
the destination IP address port and the
protocol so it is basically uh the
network security group sits on the
instances and uh or virtual machines and
they basically Define that how the
traffic should be reaching to the ports
onto the virtual Ma machine so how do
you want to open up the ports and for
which IP addresses you want to open up
the ports that is something the end user
or the administrator has to specify or a
design so they act as a kind of a
firewall rules only that protects the
virtual
machines so how to launch an instance
using Azure vet so first of all you have
to create a virtual Network so virtual
Network act as a container for subnets
so first thing is that you would be
creating a virtual Network then you
would be creating subnets which are
considered as a subset within the
virtual Network so Cloud instances
included in the subnet so first wets are
created then the subnets are created and
then you configure the properties in the
security group have a look at this in
detail now with respect to the virtual
Network what you need to do is you have
to create a virtual Network in the Azure
Cloud then you have to create subnets
into each virtual Network which is kind
of a subset of a virtual Network so you
can create one as a public subnet the
other one as a private subnet for
example now you have to assign instances
so when you create an instance you have
to specify that what is the virtual
Network for which virtual Network you're
creating an instance within that virtual
Network you have to select that on which
particular subnet the instance should be
created and then connect instance to a
relevant network security group so
attach your network security group to
the instance es and based on the
properties or the rules that are defined
in the network security group that will
be applied to the instances within the
subnets finally configure the properties
in the network security and set the
policies as a result you'll be able to
launch your instance on Azure within the
virtual Network now we will be seeing
one demo that how we can create Azure
virtual Network subnets and the network
security group so just be there uh to
watch our demo on the Azure virtual
Network in today's session I would be
showing how you can create the virtual
networks onto the Azure and for that you
require the credentials on Microsoft
Azure and here you can see on my screen
that I have already logged in into the
Azure console now what you need to do is
uh in order to search virtual Network
you can type and search in the dashboard
uh in the search bar uh with respect to
the virtual
networks and here you can
find uh the virtual Network and the
gateways so what you need to do is you
just have to click on the virtual
networks and then it will give you the
options to add the components inside the
virtual networks so let me first uh open
up uh the virtual
Network right now in theory we discussed
that the virtual network comprises of
multiple components and subcomponents so
primarily is that first you have to
create a virtual Network then you have
to assign the ipv4 cidr block to the
virtual
Network and then you create the subnets
inside the network which is a subset of
the virtual Network along with that you
define the routing rules and uh likewise
you create the instances inside the
subnets that will be part of the virtual
networks so that's what we are going to
do uh in this demo so I would be adding
up a new virtual Network so you can see
here there are already two virtual
networks that have been added one is the
demo wiet which is by default so when
you created the assure credentials the
demo virtual network was already created
by the Azure so that it can provide you
the default settings and then the test
one has been created by me and uh that's
the customized one or you can say a non-
default virtual Network so I'll I'm
going to add another wiet and U would
Define the name to it
so let's wait for the details to appear
so here you have to define the virtual
Network to create uh obviously we will
be going with the free trial only and
then you have to create a resource Group
so what is a resource Group it is
primarily a collection of resources that
share the same life cycle permissions
and the policies so if you have a
resource Group uh created you can use it
otherwise you can create a new Resource
Group so I already have one that is the
demo one I would be using using that in
the instance details you have to specif
the name of the virtual Network so these
are
certain uh parameters that you have to
go with uh while defining the name so
let's say I put something like test wiet
as uh the virtual Network that I want to
create and that is you have to select a
region where you want to get that uh
created so these are the available
regions that you can select I would go
with um Us East uh East us only and then
we have to define the IP addresses
also so in the IP addresses uh the cidr
blocks are allocated to the virtual
networks and that becomes a fixed IP
address for that vet so what you can do
is you can specify a range of IP
addresses now whenever we talk about a
virtual Network and the IP addresses we
primarily focus on the private IPS only
so this is the private IP that we are
actually uh talking about so I can
reserve some
IP address cidr for our wiet and that is
the range of 4.0.0
z/6 I'm going to reserve so now we'll
create one subnet and uh we'll name that
subnet so as we discussed that subnets
are the subc components of uh the vnet
so here you can see we have already
created one U subnet with the name
public subnet so likewise we can add
another subnet also and uh let's name it
to something like uh demo subnet right
and the subnet should have the IP
address range and that IP address range
should be part of the vet only in uh so
same subnet address range you would be
defining in the subnet as well so that
will be 40.0 do1 dot or we can select
2.0
sl24 the rest of the things uh would be
default we are not attaching any route
table as of now so just click on okay
and here you can see that the subnet is
created now once the subnet is created
now we are going to create a virtual
machine inside that subnet and for that
we'll go to the search bar and here
we'll type virtual
machines now we'll create a virtual
machine in the same wiet that is the
test vet and inside the demo subnet so
that our virtual machine gets the
private IP address from uh the subnet
that has been created in the wiet itself
so what you need to do is you have to
open up the virtual machines click on
ADD and here you should add a new
virtual
machine so you should uh select the name
of the virtual machine and uh the
network details where we would be
defining the vet as well as the subnet
where the virtual machine should be
created so in the subscription we'll go
with the freetail and in the resource
Group we'll go with the demo that has
already been created we'll put a virtual
machine name uh something like uh test
uh VM and the rest of the things will be
default so we'll quickly skip the disk
check also now in the networking we
would be
selecting the test vet as our virtual
Network and in the subnet we would be
selecting the demo subnet so that is the
re recently one added in the test vet
and we want that our virtual machine
should be part of that subnet only now
obviously since we are creating a
virtual machine so it should be part of
it should have the public IP also
assigned since uh from the public
network we need to access those virtual
machines so we'll keep it enabled right
and the next uh would be the default
settings that we are going to proceed
with so let's uh review all the
configurations and
then create your virtual
machine so here you can see that our
virtual machine has been created
validation has been passed and it takes
couple of minutes to get that updated so
let's wait for a few more minutes so
that our virtual machine is ready and
primarily what we want to look into is
that our virtual machine is created in a
correct wet and it gets uh the private
IP address from the subnet that has been
part of the uh vet uh which has been
defined in the creation of a virtual
machine so let's wait for a couple of
more minutes and uh we'll look into the
status of the
me now you can see here our test virtual
machine has been created now what we
wanted to look into is that our virtual
machine is created in a correct subnet
or not and that is something which we
can validate by checking the private IP
address so it got the private IP from
the range of uh the IP address that we
have specified in the subnet now in
order to access this particular virtual
machine you have to use the public IP
since uh since uh we have to access it
from the internet so from the private IP
this virtual machine will not be
accessible so that's the reason that
when we created a virtual machine we
allocated the public IP address also for
this
instance so that is with respect to uh
the virtual Network and the
demonstration on it and how we can
create a vet and the subcomponents of
the vet how they are associated or
interl with each other and that actually
creates a kind of an isolated
environment on the public Cloud which
gives you the understanding that you can
work into uh just like an on Prim
environment only hi guys I'm rul from
Simply learn and today I'd like to
welcome you all to the greatest debate
of the century today I'm joined by two
giants of the cloud computing industry
they'll be going head-to-head with each
other to decide who amongst them is
better it's going to be one hell of a
fight now let's meet our candidates on
my left we have AWS who's voiced by AA
hi guys and on my right we have
Microsoft aor who's voiced by Angelie
hey there so today we'll be deciding
who's better on the basis of their
origin and the features they provide
their performance on the present day and
comparing them on the basis of pricing
market share and options free tier and
instance configuration now let's listen
to their opening statements let's start
with AWS launched in 2006 AWS is one of
the most commonly used cloud computing
platforms across the world companies
like Adobe Netflix Airbnb HTC Pinterest
and Spotify have put their faith in ews
for their proper functioning it also
dominates the cloud computing domain
with almost 40% of the entire market
share so far nobody's even gotten close
to beating that number AWS also provides
a wide range of service
that covers a great number of domains
domains like compute networking storage
migration and so much more now let's see
what Azor has to say about that Azure
was launched in 2010 and is trusted by
almost 80% of all Fortune 500 companies
the best of the best companies in the
world choose to work only with Azure
Azure also provides its services to more
regions than any other cloud service
provider in the world Azure covers 42
regions of already and 12 more are being
planned to be made AA also provides more
than 100 Services spanning a variety of
domains now that the opening statements
are done let's have a look at the
current market status of each of our
competitors this is the performance
round here we have the stats for the
market share of AWS Azo and other cloud
service providers this is for the early
2018 period Amazon web services takes up
a whopping 40% of the market share
closely followed by aor at 30% and other
cloud services adding 30% this 40%
indicates most organizations clear
interest in using AWS we are number one
because of our years of experience and
Trust we've created among our users sure
you're the market leader but we are not
very far behind let me remind you more
than 80% of the Fortune 500 companies
trust Azure with their cloud computing
needs so it's only a matter of time
before aure takes the lead the rest of
the 30% that that is an AWS orazure
accounts to the other cloud service
providers like Google Cloud platform
Rackspace IBM softlayer and so on now
for our next round the comparison round
first we'll be comparing pricing we'll
be looking at the cost of a very basic
instance which is a virtual machine of
two virtual CPUs and 8 GBS of RAM for
AWS this will cost you approximately
0.928 us per R and for the same instance
in AAR it'll cost you approximately
0.096 us per hour next up let's compare
market share and options as I mentioned
before AWS is the Undisputed market
leader when it comes to the cloud
computing domain taking up 40% of the
market share by 2020 AWS is also
expected to produced twice its current
Revenue which comes close to $44 billion
not to mention AWS is constantly
expanding its already strong roster of
more than 100 services to fulfill the
shifting business requirements of
organizations all that is great really
good for you but the research company
Gardner has released a magic quadrant
that you have to see you see the
competition is now neck to neck between
Azure and AWS it's only a matter of time
before Azure can increase from its 30%
market share and surpass AWS this
becomes more likely considering how all
companies are migrating from AWS to
Azure to help satisfy their business
needs Azure is not far behind AWS when
this comes to Services as well aure
service offerings are constantly updated
and improved on to help users satisfy
their cloud computing requirements now
let's compare AWS and azz's free
offerings AWS provides a significant
number of services for free helping
users get hands-on experience with the
platform products and services the free
tier Services fall under two categories
services that will remain free forever
and the others that are valid only for
one year year the always free category
offers more than 20 services for example
Amazon SNS sqs cloudwatch Etc and the
valid for a year category offers
approximately 20 services for example
Amazon S3 ec2 elastic cash Etc both
types of services have limits on the
usage for example storage number of
requests compute time Etc but users are
only charged for using services that
fall under the valid for a year category
after after a year of their usage a show
provides a free tier as well it also
provides services that belong to the
categories of free for year and always
free there are about 25 plus always free
services provided by aure these include
app service functions container service
active directory and lots more and as of
the valid for a year there are eight
services offered there's Linux or
Windows Virtual machines blob storage
SQL database and few more aure also also
provides the users with credits of
$200 to access all their services for 30
days now this is a unique feature that
Azure provides where it users can use
their credits to utilize any service of
a choice for the entire month now let's
compare instance configuration the
largest instance that AWS offers is that
of a warping 256 GBS of RAM and 16
virtual CPUs the largest that aure
offers isn't very far behind either 224
GBS of RAM and 16 virtual CPUs and now
for the final round now each of our
contestants will be shown facts and they
have to give explanations for these
facts we call it the rapid fire round
first we have features in which AWS is
good and Azure is better AWS does not
cut down on the features it offers its
users however it requires slightly more
Management on the users part aure goes
slightly deeper with the services that
fall under certain categories like
platform as a service and infrastructure
as a service next we have hybrid Cloud
where AWS is good and Azure is better
okay although AWS did not emphasize on
hybrid Cloud earlier they are focusing
more on technology now Azure has always
emphasized on hybrid cloud and has
features supporting it since the days of
its inception for developers AWS is
better and Azure is good of course it's
better because AWS supports integration
with third party applications well well
Azure provides access to data centers
that provide a scalable architecture for
pricing both AWS and Azure are at the
same level it's good for AWS because it
provides a competitive and constantly
decreasing pricing model and in the case
of aure it provides offers that are
constantly experimented upon to provide
its users with the best experience and
that's it our contestants have finished
giving their statements now let's see
who won surprisingly nobody each cloud
Computing platform has its own pros and
cons choosing the right one is based
entirely on your organization's
requirements so if you are interested in
becoming an Azure certified professional
then consider simply learns Azure Cloud
architect Masters program Azure Cloud
architect Masters program will help you
master the Azure infrastructure by
understanding Azure Cloud architect
Technology Solutions implementing
workloads and Security in Azure creating
and deploying apps in Azure and securing
data in azure job now who should take
this program fresher graduates who are
intent on taking the plunge into the job
market second professionals with less
than two years of experience who are
working in either technical or
non-technical job roles and want to
shift to the cloud so what are you
waiting for androll now get certified
and get
ahead this video is based on Microsoft
Azure certifications Microsoft Azure is
a cloud provider that holds the second
highest market share in the US after
Amazon web services according to
quickstart.com plenty of companies are
switching to Microsoft Azure this proves
that companies across the world embrace
the cloud computing which means the
popularity of Microsoft Azure services
and Azure professionals is on the rise
the salaries of azure professionals are
pretty much higher compared to
professionals working on other
Technologies in the United States of
America salaries of Azure developers
range from 1 lak1 15,000 to
175,000
us so you're thinking about taking up an
Azure Cloud certification in that case I
could definitely help you in this video
I'll be talking about Azure
certifications which will help you grow
your career some of you must be
wondering which certification is the
right choice for your career don't worry
we will be discussing that as well in
this
session before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
that Bell icon to never miss an update
from Simply learn coming back to the
topic let me tell you that Microsoft
aszure certification consists of 13
certificates and all these
certifications are organized into four
levels fundamental level associate level
expert level and speciality level now
let's get started with the first
certification azure
fundamental exam
ac900 this is a very basic level of
certification for candidates who are
willing to begin their career in Azure
cloud computing now the skills covered
in this certificate are core Azure
Concepts like high availability ha
scalability fault tolerance ft disaster
recovery scalability of applications and
the difference between cap X and opx
cap X is defined as a business expenses
and Opex is the operation cost next is
deep understanding of relational and
non-relational data on Asha then comes
analytics workloads modern data
warehousing and Azure Architectural
Components on Azure then knowledge of
data inje data visualization Azure
firewall DS protection and network
security group now moving forward it's
time to know the important details of
this examination coming to prerequisites
there are no prerequisites for this
certification which means it is launched
especially for non- tiies next this exam
consists of 30 to 40 questions which
should be answered within 60 Minutes the
minimum passing score required for this
certification is 700 points and finally
comes the cost the cost for this
certification is $99
us moving forward let's talk about our
next certification which is Microsoft
certified Azure AI fundamentals exam AI
bab this certification is designed for
individuals who are willing to learn the
basic knowledge of how to implement
artificial intelligence machine learning
on Microsoft Azure let us talk about the
topics covered in this
certification understanding the core
concept and features of common
artificial int ENT workloads and guiding
principles of AI basic principle of
machine learning on aure and features of
computer version workloads on Azure next
comes the process of identifying common
types of computer equation solution
knowledge of azure tools and services
for computer vision tasks then it is
important to understand the concept of
azure tools and services for NLP
workloads which is covered in this
certification next is conversational AI
workloads on Azure finally it involves
the process of identifying common use
cases for conversational AI aure
Services now moving forward it's time to
know the important details of this
Examination for this certification there
are no prerequisites and the cost of
completing this certificate is
$99 next we will talk about the third
certification that is Microsoft
certified your data fundamentals exam
dp900
beta the certification will give the
knowledge of core database Concepts such
as relational and non-relational
databases so that they can be
implemented on Microsoft AO architecture
now let us jump right into the topics
covered in this
certification first the exam covers the
core data workloads batch and streaming
data of data
analytics next it it has the concept of
relational Azure data services such as
comparison of
paas
iiaas and saas delivery models then
comes identification of fundamental
management task of relational database
and various techniques in describing
query techniques for data using SQL
language next comes the concept of non
relational database workloads and non-
relational data offerings on aure then
it covers the analytics workloads and
components of modern data warehouse now
moving forward it's time to know the
important details of this examination
the certificate requires no
prerequisits next the cost the cost for
this certification is $99
amican now talking about the next
service that is the Microsoft aure
administrator associate exam ac1
103 it is an associate level Microsoft
Azure
certification it trains a candidate by
improvising and individual skill in
implementing monitoring and managing
Asha
services so let's jump right into the
topics covered in this certification it
helps in understanding the management of
azure resources groups and role-based
access next creating and configuring
storage accounts Azure files and aure
backup concepts are explained then the
concept of deploying and managing
virtual machines and VM backups are
covered next comes the concept of
configuration and management of visual
networks implementation of asol load
balancer and network security group
finally it also covers the concept of
creating and managing Azure active
directory ad objects users and groups
talking about the exam detail
this exam requires completion of
Microsoft aure fundamentals exam
a900 the exam consists of 40 to 60
Questions which should be answered
within 150 minutes a minimum passing
score for this certification is 15 and
talking about the cost the completion of
this certification is $160
American so going further let's talk
about the next certification Microsoft
certified aure administrator associate
exam
a104
beta this exam is conducted for the
candidates who know the configuration
and management of compute storage and
virtual networking Azure services so
let's jump right into the topics covered
in the certification it has concepts of
aure AD objects role-based Access
Control next it explains how to manage
storage accounts and data in Azure
storage and covers the different ways to
configure as as files and as blob
storage then it shows how to create and
configure VMS containers and web
applications on AA platform finally it
explains the concept of configuration
and management of virtual
networking now moving forward it's time
to know the important details of the
examination this examination has only
one free requisite that is completion of
aure fundamentals exam
ac900 the cost for this certification is
$165
American did you know that exam a104 is
updated version of certificate
a103 after completing this certificate
an Azure administrator is given the
responsibility of implementing Azure
based Cloud
infrastructure our next certification is
Microsoft certified Azure developer
associate exam a
203 this exam is created for the
candidates who have the knowledge of
Designing building and maintaining asure
applications and services with the
coordination of cloud database
administrators now let's see the topics
covered in the
certification first it covers the
concept of building asure resource
manager templates then it explains
simple ways of monitoring and
implementing batch jobs next it involves
the concept of building Azure app
services like web and mobile applic app
ation API applications and
implementation of aure functions then
comes the main concept it explains how
to develop solutions for usage of
storage tables blob storage Cosmos DB
storage and relational databases finally
it helps in learning the process of
implementing Azure Security in terms of
user authentication user access control
and data security if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know
more now let us discuss the examination
details as you can see on the screen
talking about prerequisits this
certification requires completion of
Microsoft Azure fundamentals exam
a900 and the exam will have 40 to 60
Questions which should be answered
within 180 minutes and finally comes the
cost the cost of test certification as
$160
American Next comes Microsoft certified
Azure security engineer associate exam
ac500 this certification helps an
individual to master the knowledge of
implementing and managing security
protocols apart from that it also
includes the concept of identity and
access management of cloud security data
so let's jump right into the topics
covered in this certification
it covers the concept of the
configuration of azure ad privileged
identity management and Azure security
next it helps an individual to learn how
to implement management security and
container Security on the applications
on Azure platform next an individual can
gain a deep understanding of concept of
azure log analytics security alerts and
security
policies finally the process of
configuration and Security Management
of data
infrastructure SSL DLS for application
is explained now let us discuss the
examination details as you can see on
the screen this certification 2 requires
the completion of Microsoft assure
fundamentals exam
a900 and the exam has a set of 40 to 60
Questions which should be answered
within 150 minutes talking about the
cost the cost for this certification
will be $165 Amic
also this exam requires strong skills in
Automation and scripting a deep
understanding of virtualization
technology and virtual networking and a
strong familiarity with Microsoft cloud
services and products moving further
let's see what our next certification is
it is as AI engineer associate exam AI
100 this certification is conducted for
candidates who have a deep understanding
of NLP
natural language processing speech
computer vision Bots and agents using
cognitive
Services now it's time to dive deep into
the topics covered in this
certification first it has the concepts
of AI models and services and
identifying automation requirements then
comes the process of how to design a
strategy for ingesting and exess data
pipelines for artificial intelligence
applications and different ways of
implementing AI Solutions in a suitable
project next is AI Concepts it helps an
individual understand how to develop AI
pipelines and Implement AI
workflow finally the management process
this certification involves the process
of monitoring artificial intelligence
components for continuous improvements
candidates appearing for this exam must
have a basic knowledge of artificial
intelligence should know which AI tools
should be used in the projects and
should have problem solving skills in
order to meet the Project's performance
requirements this certification requires
completion of Microsoft Azure
fundamentals exam
ac900 like the previous certification
the exam consists of 40 to 60 Questions
which should be answered within 180
minutes and finally comes the cost the
cost for this certification will be $165
americ now let's see what the next
certification is well it's the Microsoft
Azure data engineer associate exams
dp200 and DP
p21 let's talk about the Microsoft Azure
data engineer associate exam
dp200 this exam is designed for
candidates who want to improve their
skills in management development and
data processing now it's time to dive
deep into the topics covered in the
certification it helps an individual to
understand how to implement relational
and non-relational data storage
solutions next the certification helps
in understanding the concept of managing
data security by implementing data
masking and encrypting data in the
process then the certification helps an
individual to gain knowledge in
development streaming and badge
processing Solutions finally comes the
monitoring process and individual learn
how to monitor data storage and few
simple ways of implementing data
processing systems and how to optimize
assure Data Solutions in a business now
let's talk about the details as you can
see on the screen this certification
requires complete completion of
Microsoft AA fundamentals exam
a900 the exam consists of 40 to 50
questions which should be answered
within 180 minutes now talking about the
cost a candidate will have to pay $165
American as the exam fee next let's talk
about the exam dp21 which is launched
for designing an aure data solution this
is the second exam for becoming an Azure
data engineer it helps candidates to
improve their skills in designing data
storage models mastering the concept of
data processing and data security for
asure
services now it's time to dive deep into
the topics covered in the certification
first comes the implementation of
relational and non-relational cloud data
storage and applications next is the
designing techniques for realtime and
batch processing Solutions and provision
of compute resources then it has the
concept of Designing Security Solutions
such as encryption auditing and privacy
of data finally it is the design data
retention policies and plan archiving
strategies now let us discuss the
examination details as you can see on
the screen for the certification
completion of Microsoft Azure
fundamentals exam
ac900 next the exam consists of 40 to 50
questions which should be answered
within 150 minutes and finally comes the
cost the cost of this certific
appication will be $165
American while appearing for this exam
candidates must have an understanding of
Designing aure SQL databases Azure
Cosmos TV Azure data L Storage Azure
stream analytics and blob storage
Services okay now let's see what is the
next certification to discuss it's aure
database administrator associate exam
dp300 vaa this exam is ideal for
professionals who are willing to gain
knowledge on administering CL
cloud-based database systems now it's
time to dive deep into the topics
covered in this certification first it
consists of the basic concept of
implementing appropriate database
Solutions on selected platforms next it
tells how to implement an aure ad
authentication Service on a running
application then it explains about
monitoring activities basic concepts of
how to configure resources to achieve an
Optimal Performance next it teaches how
to review queries and base tables
finally it explains the planning and
implementation strategy for continuous
and backup services at the time of
Disaster
Recovery now let us discuss the
examination details as you can see on my
screen there are no prerequisites for
this certification talking about the
cost the exam fee is $165
American moving further let's discuss
what a Microsoft Azure Solutions
architect expert exam a300 and
ac31 are basically these are expert
level Microsoft aure certifications to
become an Azure certified Solutions
architect you have to pass two
examinations ac300 and
ac31 let's first talk about exam ac300
Microsoft Azure architect Technologies
this exam is suitable for architects who
are the advocate for their business to
achieve this certification an individual
should have advanced knowledge in it
operations including virtualization data
security networking and business
continuity now it's time to dive deep
into the topics covered in the
certification first comes the concept of
analyzing resource utilization and
management of azure active directory
next comes how to migrate an application
to Azure and different ways to manage
rule-based access then it explains how
to build configure and Run apps in aure
kuity service AKs
finally it explains how to implement MFA
that is multiactor authentication for
users on Azure platform now let's
discuss the examination details as you
can see on my screen for this
certification completion of Microsoft
asure fundamentals exam
E900 is necessary next the exam consists
of 40 to 60 Questions which should be
answered within 150 minutes and finally
comes the cost the cost of the certif
ification will be
$165
American next exam is
a31 Microsoft Azure architect design
this is the next expert level exam
suitable for Azure Solutions architect
to achieve this certification the
candidate should have complete knowledge
in various aspects of ID Fields now it's
time to dive deep into the topics
covered in the certification to achieve
the certification a person should should
know how to plan networking and
monitoring strategy based on client
requirement he should be able to collect
data and infrastructure requirements and
Define logical
groupings he should be proficient in
designing data flows and data protection
strategies he should know about site
recovery and data archiving now let's
discuss the examination details as you
can see on my screen first comes
prerequisites the certification requires
completion of Microsoft azure
fundamentals exam
ac900 next this exam consists of 40 to
60 Questions which should be answered
within 150 minutes and finally comes the
cost the cost for this certification
will be $165
American Next comes the last
certification that is Microsoft aure
devops Engineer Expert exam
ac400 this certificate is suitable for
it professionals who want to become ASA
devops and Engineer Expert now it's time
to dive deep into the topics covered in
this certification to achieve the
certification a person should know how
to design a secure devops development
life cycle and Tool integration process
an individual will learn how to
implement Version Control on the project
and manage to build infrastructure next
an individual will be able to analyze
and manage an assure kuber service
infrastructure then he will be able to
Implement infrastructure as Code
Compliance and security of the
infrastructure now let us discuss the
examination details as you can see on my
screen this certification does not
require completion of ac900
certification but requires the
completion of aure administrator
associate or aure developer associate
certification the candidate should have
a general knowledge of devops Concepts
the exam consists of 40 to 60 Questions
which should be answered ConEd within
180 minutes and finally comes the cost
the cost of this certification will be
$165
americ knowing Azure is one thing having
worked on Azure is another thing and
being able to answer interview questions
in Azure is a totally different thing
although one helps the other it's still
different skills and our aim through
this video is to prepare you with common
product and scenario based interview
questions so why wait let's get started
a common Cloud interview question is
what's the difference between SAS Pas
and is we all know that a software as a
service is Thin Client model of software
provisioning where client in this case
usually is simply a web browser
providing the point of access to
softwares running on the servers now SAS
is the most familiar form of cloud
service for customers SAS moves the task
of managing software and its deployment
to thirdparty Services meaning the
vendor actually gets to manage all that
so uh SAS is software as a service
involving applications being consumed
and used by organization so it's
generally using an application and
usually organizations pay for their use
of this particular application now some
examples of SAS would include Office 365
Salesforce is another very good example
of SAS and a lot of uh Google Apps and
Storage Solutions like box and Dropbox
are a very good example of software as a
service talking about platform as a
service or pass it actually functions at
the lower level than SAS now typically
it provides a platform on which software
can be developed and deployed now here
we develop the software we deploy the
software now Pas actually provides an
abstract of much of the work dealing
with servers and giving client an
environment in which the operating
system and the server software and the
Hardwares and the network are managed
and taken care in other words with a
platform as a service all the things
that I've mentioned like the servers the
server software the hardware everything
is managed by the provider and we can
focus on business side of the
scalability and we can focus on
application development of our product
or the service so in short platform as a
service is a service that enables
developers to build and work with
applications without even having to
worry about the infrastructure or
management of the underlying hosting
environments and some examples of pass
in Azure is SQL and Azure storage
talking about infrastructure as a
service I as now this is moving down the
stack even further now we get to the
fundamental building block of the cloud
service which is infrastructure as a
service IAS now I is fully of Highly
automated scalable Computer Resources I
is full of storage I is full of the
network capability that's what is is now
is clients have direct access to the
servers and storage just as they would
to do traditional servers but in this
case it's going to be in the cloud in
this case it's going to be more scalable
so I is very similar to what you would
do in your on premises physical data
center but when we talk about I we get
to do everything but it's stored in the
cloud so if we need to build a
definition around I IAS or
infrastructure as a service provides
users with components it provides
components it does not give us an built
environment it simply provides a
component such as operating system uh
networking capabilities and a lot more
now this is a p paid for based on the
usage and can be used to host
applications in other words this is pay
as you go type the more you use the more
you pay the less you use the less you
pay and some of the examples of IAS in
Azure is virtual machine that's a great
example for IAS and vets for networking
that's another good example for IAS in
Azure another common question in Azure
interview is what are the instant types
offered by Azure the main intention of
this question is how well have you
understood the different offerings in
Azure and how well are you trained to
pick the right offering for the right
service now one size does not fit all
and there are there are a lot of
services in Azure that under the carpet
it does the same thing but depending on
how different your requirement is we'll
have to pick the appropriate service so
this actually this question what are the
different instant types offered by Azure
it's to test how well have you used the
product product and services available
in Azure and how well have you applied
them for the given requirement you
shouldn't be provisioning more you
shouldn't be provisioning less at the
same time so it's kind of matching the
right service to the right requirement
so what are the instant types offered by
Azure as you see in the list we have
general purpose computer optimized
memory optimized storage optimized GPU
virtual machines and high performance
compute virtual machines now answering
just the names won't be enough in an
interview you'll have to go further and
explain why and in What scenario you
would use general purpose and what are
the use cases what type of servers is a
good fit for a general purpose and what
type is a good fit for computer
optimized so on and so forth and that's
exactly what we're going to do now so
the gentle purpose VMS you know they
provide a balanced CPU to memory ratio
and it's very good for testing very good
for development environment very good
for small and medium databases and and
also for low to medium traffic web
servers and some of the use cases are
like we said test servers low traffic
web servers small to medium databases
some Enterprise grade applications it's
also good for relational database it's
also good for uh servers used for
in-memory caching it's also good for
some small analytic uh database very
good for microservices and if you're
trying to build a proof of concept for
an idea that you just have or just
parked uh this is another good server
for doing proof of Concepts because
you're not going to send actual traffic
to it I just want to show that you know
your idea works so general purpose
server is a very good use case for those
scenarios and the largest instance size
uh we can get in general purpose is
standard d64 V3 uh which comes with 256
GB of memory and ,600 GB of SSD
temporary storage on the other hand
compute optimized VMS have an a high CPU
to memory ratio and are very good for
medium traffic web servers very good for
batch processing servers very good for
application servers now because it's
computer optimized and compute means a
CPU it's an excellent choice for
workloads that demand faster CPU but
does not need as much memory or
temporary storage virtual CPU some of
the workloads that run very well on
computer optimized are analytic
workloads uh gaming servers require more
CPU they run really well uh batch
processing are some of the applications
that can be placed in computer optimized
and by doing that we get the actual
benefit of the computer optimized
instance and the largest instance size
or the largest instance size type is
standard f72 V2 and here we get 144 GB
of memory and 576 GB of SSD temporary
storage in compute optimized VMS in the
same lines memory optimized VM they
offer High memory to CPU ratio and that
are great for databases databases
require more memory so it's a great fit
for database and uh it's a great fit for
medium to uh large scale caches
applications that require inmemory
analytics so this memory optimized
memories more so it's very good for
inmemory Analytics applications and the
largest instant size we get here is
standard m128 M and look at the um
gigabit of memory it's uh
3892 GB of memory and uh look at the uh
temporary storage it's uh
336 GB of temporary storage on the same
lines storage optimized now I guess I
don't have to explain to you what
storage optimized is used for you might
have easily guessed looking at the flow
yes storage optimized Wim offer High
disk throughput and IO and are very
ideal for Big Data uh SQL no SQL
databases data warehousing servers large
transactional databases and lot more and
some of the examples of the applications
that can be launched on storage
optimized are Cassandra mongod DB Cloud
era redis these are some familiar
applications that can get benefited when
we run them on storage optimized and one
difference between storage optimized and
the other servers are they are generally
optimized to use the local disc on the
Node attached directly to the VM rather
than using an durable dis which is
actually an a remote uh disk space now
what does this allow this allows for
greater input outputs per second or uh
throughput for the workload so that's
what we get a greater throughput a
greater input output per second is what
we get when we use storage optimized and
the largest instant size available in
storage optimized is standard uh L 32s
and U uh the memory is 256 GB and look
at the temporary storage it's uh
5630 GB of temporary storage GPU type
VMS easy to guess uh GPU optimized VMS
are specialized virtual machines
available with u multiple gpus at
attached to them now these sizes are
designed for or these VMS are designed
for computer intensive graphic intensive
visualization workflows that require a
lot of um graphical Processing Unit
attached to it so in short these are
virtual machines that specialize in
heavy graphic rendering and video
editing it also helps with the model
training and interferences with the a
standard nd24 RS which has a 448 GB of M
memory and
2948 GB of temporary storage and the
last but not the least but the best last
but the best is high performance
computer or Azure H series virtual
machines now they are the latest in high
performance Computing VMS and are aimed
to handle workloads like batch
processing analytic molecular modeling
and fluid dynamics lot of complicated
applications in this uh VM and this is
the fastest and Powerful CPU virtual
machine with the optional High
throughput interfaces and the largest
instance size that's available is
standard l32 s which comes with 224 GB
of memory and 200 GB of SSD temporary
storage and a third common question is
what are the deployment environments
offered by Azure there are two main
deployment environments one is the
staging environment and the other one is
the production environment now in
staging environment let's talk about
staging first so when you're are
deploying a web app or web app on Linux
you can deploy them to a separate slot
instead of the default production slot
when running them in standard premium or
isolated app service PL tiers now the
deployment slots are actually live app
with their own host name and at a later
point the staging environment can be
swapped with the production environment
so why do we need an staging environment
what are the benefit of it so the
benefit of deploying our application to
a nonproduction or staging environment
it provides a platform to validate
changes to our application before it can
be made live in the production
environment and in the staging
environment the app can be identified
using the azure's global unique
identifier also called as the guid URL
and it's very very similar to the
production URL except up that it has an
custom name in front of it that
identifies it as the staging environment
and for production environment uh this
is the live uh production environment
that's serving customers's request
that's serving the customer content now
it can be slightly different from the
staging environment in a way that the
URL that's used to identify the
production environment that's more of an
DNS friendly name like the name of the
actual service
. Cloud
app.net that way it differs in case of
staging environment you have an custom
name right before it so the custom name
and then the cloud app.net but in this
case you get the uh direct service name
as the name of the URL so this is live
production environment which receives
and handles and serves customer traffic
another commonly asked question in Azure
is what are the advantages of scaling in
Azure the actual thought thought behind
the question is to see how much have you
understood scaling how much have you
seen and how much have you applied the
scaling effect in the production
environment and have received benefits
in return so let's talk about it
advantages of scaling in Azure some of
the advantages are we get the maximum
application performance now Autos
scaling is a built-in feature for the
cloud services be it um AWS Azure Google
and a couple of other cloud service
providers it's a built-in feature for a
cloud service a cloud service should be
Autos scalable and that includes mobile
services virtual machines and um when we
run our applications uh on mobile
services or virtual machines the website
actually gets the best performance uh
during the change in the demand again
different applications uh might require
different uh performance needs for
example for some apps the performance
measured based on memory and another
good good example is the fluctuating
demand for example you could have a web
app that handles millions of requests
during the day and literally nothing at
the night and Autos scaling this
environment Autos scaling any of these
environment will automatically scale or
fatten your environment so to receive
the all the incoming traffic and during
lean period it actually gets Slimmer and
Slimmer uh so to help you with the cost
so it actually maximizes uh the
performance that's what autos scaling
does and like we said Auto scaling
scales up and scales Down based on
demand it not only scales up but also
scales down so to help you with the cost
and if you know the particular pattern
in which the application is going to
receive uh traffic then we can very well
go ahead and schedule scaling to our
application or schedule scaling that
infrastructure based on time if we
already know that Monday to Friday
that's the traffic uh that I would get
and it's a constant one it's not a
public facing but you know it's an
internal application so I know all the
500 users or the th000 or the 5,000
users who will be using it so at any
given point it's just 5,000 users it's
not going to go beyond that and during
Saturday and Sunday literally nobody's
going to be in office so no load at all
so in that case I pretty much know how
the pattern is going to be I can go for
schedule scaling if I know the pattern
and Autos scaling like I said not only
helps with keeping the application
highly available it also helps with the
cost effectiveness of our infrastructure
so anytime there's a VM or a group of
VMS running on less CPU Autos scaling is
going to actually get the environment
Slimmer and Slimmer so we're not
unnecessarily running any resources and
paying for it if you're being
interviewed for the infra site in Azure
this is another common question that
gets asked how are Windows Active
Directory and Azure active uh directory
different let's talk about the Windows
Active Directory first the non-cloud
Windows Active Directory was the service
was released along with Windows 2000
server Edition and this active directory
is essentially a database that helps
organizations to organize the users
organize the computers and a lot more it
provides authentication and
authorization to the applications not
only to the applications but also to
file servers to printers and lot of
other on premises uh resources that's
what the basic non-cloud active
directory does on the other hand the
Azure active directory is not designed
to manage web-based services the Azure
active directory on the other hand was
designed to support web based services
that use rest API interfaces for office
uh 365 salesforce.com Etc unlike the
plain active directory this uses an
completely different protocol so
protocol wise it's different and the
services that it support is quite
different now besides that it also has a
couple of other differences as well and
let's look at them so the actual active
directory or the windows actual
directory is a directory service that
facilitates working with interconnected
complex and different network resources
in a very unified manner on the other
hand Azure active directory is
Microsoft's multi-tenant cloud-based
directory and identity management
service and the Windows Active Directory
has five layers to store data to store
user details and to is the management
certifications on the other hand Azure
active directory integrates or
compresses the five layers into just two
layers here Windows Active Directory
works with on premises servers like
applications file servers and printers
Etc on the other hand Azure active
directory it uh works on web- Based
Services that use restful interfaces if
you're being hired for the development
environment or for the um cloud devops
support environment or even for the
production support environment you might
find yourself being asked this question
what are the types of cues offered by
Azure now Azure supports two types of
queue mechanisms the storage queue and
the service bus queue Let's Talk About
Storage queue first now the storage
queue which are part of azure storage
infrastructure it provides a simple rest
based uh interface simple rest based get
put and Peak interface it provides
reliable persistent messaging within and
between the services it follows the pub
sub model or a pub sub messaging
infrastructure and it's best suited for
users that need to store more than 80 GB
of messages in the cube it can provide
logs for all the transactions executed
against the users queue so that's what
we get with storage queue and on the
other hand service bus cu the service
bus cues are built on top of broader
messaging infrastructure and they are
designed to integrate applications an
applications component that can span
multiple communication protocol so that
way it differs so this is good for
applications and components that may
span multiple communication protocols
and even different totally different
network environments so in short these
service buses or the service bus cues in
Azure are part of azure's messaging
infrastructure and they uh integrate
application or application components
that can actually span multiple
different protocols and multiple
different network environments it also
provides an first and first out style
for delivery and the user Q size has to
remain under 80 gbit another familiar
question is what are the advantages of
azure resource manager now the resource
manager helps us to manage the usage of
the application resources this question
is actually to test how well have you
tested how well have you used resource
manager and have gotten the benefit of
it this question actually tests how easy
it has become after the introduction of
resource manager compared to uh when
doing deployments or when provisioning
resources without the resource manager
so let's get into the answers for the
question what are the advantages of
azure resource manager the inur resource
manager is called armm so the armm helps
deploy manage and monitor all the
resources for an application a solution
or a group so all the interconnected
application all the interconnected
Services can be monitored as group using
resource manager and users can be
granted to access to resources that they
require within a resource manager so in
an account I can have like 10 different
resources created by resource manager or
a resource Group created by resource
managers and I can allow deny connection
to those services or only to those
Services based on whether the user
should be accessing one and not
accessing the other so that way it
becomes easy to give access to a group
of application it helps in getting U
billing details for the group of
resources now which group is using more
which group is using less and which
group has contributed more to this
month's bill stuff like that so those
details can be obtained using Azure
resour manager and provisioning
resources is made much easier uh with
the help of this resource manager
another question is how has integrating
hybrid Cloud been useful for Azure well
with the use of hybrid Cloud we get the
best of both the worlds so what's hybrid
Cloud it's nothing but combining the
public cloud and the private cloud and
allowing data and applications to be
shared uh between them so whenever the
compute or the processing demand
fluctuates hybrid cloud computing gives
businesses the ability to seamlessly
scale their on premises infrastructure
in the public cloud and handle any kind
of uh uh overflow in the requirement or
overflow in in handling the application
so it really helps it helps it boost the
productivity of our on premises
application so with the hybrid uh Cloud
we get a greater efficiency with
combination of azure Services uh devops
process and tools for the application
running in on premises and by having an
hybrid Cloud environment users can take
advantage of a constantly updated Azure
service and other AWS Marketplace um
applications for the on premises
environment and the other benefit is uh
with hybrid Cloud environment we can
simply deploy applications regardless of
its locations in case of on premises
we'll have to worry about the location
but when we expand our on premises
environment in the cloud and they can or
we can pick any of the locations and
simply deploy it in them and this
enables the applications to be created
at a greater speed what's federating in
Azure SQL now this question is very
specific about SQL how can we scale the
SQL database now this is a very good
question or a valid question or an
important question in the interview
because many customers or companies have
not been able to meet the user demand
because they could not scale out uh the
databases uh the theory of scaling out
or adding servers to accommodate the
increased workflows and traffic is not
hard to understand but uh the
implications can be very complicated the
implications can be very expensive we
well aware of scaling the web service
that's very common but how do we scale
the database so Microsoft provides the
tools and Technologies so we can scale
out the database in the cloud and that's
what is called SQL or Federation in
Azure SQL so the way we scale out the
SQL database is by shing shing the
database so Shing actually enables users
to take advantages of the resources in
the cloud not only that it allows users
to have their own database or shared
database amongst each other because
we're creating an highly available
database because we having shards in a
database it actually reduces the
possibility of a single point of failure
for our database and more importantly
because we're sharting uh because we're
using Federation and Azure SQL it
provides an cost effective scaling of
our databases by using Cloud resources
or by using billing only for the cloud
resources that we have used so no
pre-provisioning no over-provisioning it
Provisions the right amount and we pay
the right amount let's talk about this
one what are the different types of
storage offered by Azure now the
different types of storage offered by
Azure are as you already know and as you
can see they are Azure blob storages
table storages file storage and Q
storage so let's expand one after the
other now blob storage are nothing but a
massive scalable object storage and
that's very good for storing text and uh
binary data and Azure blob storage is U
Microsoft's object storage solution for
the cloud and blob storage is optimized
for storing massive massive amount of
unstructured data that can be in form of
text or or in form of binary data so in
short blob storage enables users to
store unstructured data and those data
can be in the format of pictures music
video files and lot more and it stores
them along with their metadata and
another advantage or another feature
benefit that we get from blob storage is
when object is changed it is verified to
ensure it is of the latest version
number one and number two it provides
maximum flexibility to optimize the
users's storage needs and this
unstructured data is available to
customers through an URL or an rest
based object storage so they are the
benefits that come along with The Blob
storage table storage on on the other
hand is an a nosql store for schema Less
storage of secured data now this Azure
table storage is a service that stores
structured no SQL data in the cloud and
because this table is a schema less it's
very easy to save your data it's very
easy to adapt your uh data as the need
for your application grows and this
table storage is very fast and cost
effective for many type of applications
so some of the some of the type of data
that we can store is U table storage is
good for flexible databases like user
data for web applications address book
storage device information storage and
if you want to store metadata this is a
very good use case to store them in
Azure table storage Azure files is
another storage uh here it's an managed
file share for cloud or on premises uh
deployment so file storage provides file
sharing capabilities accessible by the
server messaging block protocol and this
can be accessed from the cloud and this
can be accessed from on premises as well
uh here in file storage the data is
protected by SMB uh 3.0 and https uh
protocols and the more important thing
is azure takes care of managing hardware
and the operating system deployments for
Azure file storage so this additional
file storage can be used uh when we want
to burst the storage capacity in on
premises so on Prem the primary and
cloud is the secondary or the extended
on- premises storage so it actually
improves the on premises performance and
capabilities for our on premises Data
Center and then we have cues Azure cues
it's a messaging store for Reliable
messaging between the application
components we spoke a little about this
uh in the previous question so the Azure
Q storage is a service for storing a
large amount of messages that can be
accessed from anywhere in the world via
HTTP or https uh protocol in here the uh
a single message can be up to 64
kilobits in size and in a queue we can
have millions of messages and the limit
can actually go up if we have not
reached the limit of the storage account
so it's millions and millions of
requests that can be stored in the
storage que or the Q storage so the Q
storage in short uh provides message Q
for large workloads and it enables users
to build flexible applications and
separate the functions one from another
so one failing doesn't affect the other
application which is running healthy and
this C Storage it ensures the
application is scalable and less prone
to individual component uh failures
because they are decoupled separate now
it also helps in monitoring the queue
which ensures the customers's demands
are met so Q is a great place to monitor
or a great component to monitor so we
understand um how much Peak can be
reached for a particular application
service or a container what is text
analysis API in Azure machine learning
now a text analysis is actually an
cloudbased analytics API and it provides
an advanced natural language processing
over the raw text and it has got uh four
main functions like the sentiment
analysis uh and the key phrase analysis
language uh deduction and and a few
other things now what do you mean by
sentiment analysis now sentiment
analysis is from the logs from the
commments from the text commands that we
receive do an analysis and find out
whether that an positive or an negative
statement now if it is a the API the API
returns and sentiment score between zero
and one and one is positive and zero is
negative and then in text analysis we we
have a key phrase extraction which is it
will automatically extract the key
phrase to a quickly identify the main
points in that uh key phrase for example
if you're analyzing an text which says
the food was delicious and there were
wonderful stuff then the API Returns the
main talking points of that phrase like
food food is the main talking point and
wonderful staffs that was a main talking
point so that's another feature that
this uh text analysis has and then we
have language deduction in text analysis
right irrespective of what you paste it
can try to gauge and try to align it to
the 120 or up to 120 languages that it
supports so I can simply take text from
the internet and I can paste it and text
analysis software is going to identify
the language and then can run phrase and
sentiment analysis on those text right
so in short text analysis is an API a
set of web services that can be used for
text analysis it can be used to analyze
unstructured statement sentiment
analysis key phrase extraction and lot
more and the results are generally
between zero and one and one being
positive and zero being the negative
sentiment there is no much training or
in other words this is not as
complicated as couple of other text
analysis softwares are available in the
market we can simply paste we can simply
upload the text and we can call the
service and it runs a sentiment analysis
on it all by itself let's look at this
question what are the advantages of
azure Q storage if you're going to work
in a development environment if you're
going to work in an environment that
Embraces devops this could be a question
what are the advantages of azure Q
storage now Azure Q storage is built to
flexibly operate the applications and
separate the functions between the the
applications that run large workloads so
when we design applications for scale
these applications can be decoupled so
that they can scale independently you
know a thing happening on an application
is not dependent on another application
and anything happens to an section of
the application will not affect the
other application because they are now
decoupled and connected through the Q
storage so the Q storage gives us
asynchronous message queuing for
communication between the applications
irrespective of whether they are running
in the cloud or whether they are running
in desktop or whether they are running
on premises or on mobile devices so in
short this Q storage enables message
queuing for large workloads in a simple
and cost effective and a durable manner
talking about the advantages advantages
is it provides Rich client libraries for
Java Android C++ PHP Ruby and lot other
services getting added
during every new release from Azure and
the main advantage again is it enables
users to build flexible apps and uh
separate the functions for bigger or
greater durability again introduction of
cues into our application it ensures our
users applications are scalable and less
prone to individual component failures
meaning one component failing is not
going to take the whole application down
right if one component fails it's just
that component that stay fails the rest
are healthy and the rest are going to
function it also helps us to monitor the
cues and ensure the servers are
overhelmed by sudden traffic burst so
how much do I have in the queue uh kind
of determines the traffic for my
application and if the queue is more I
can always go and autoscale my
environment and the queue is less I can
always go and Shrink or make my
environment thinner so it can save cost
and anytime there is there's more data
in the queue I can Auto scale monitor
the metric and do auto scaling based on
that metric so the environment knows
that there are more datas coming in I
need to expand myself to handle that
much amount of data this is a very
common question what are the two kinds
of azure web service roles now a service
Ro is a set of managed and load balanced
virtual machines that work to perform
some task and based on what it's going
to run on top of it is it going to run
web service or is it going to run worker
service defines what kind of roles that
gets attached or that goes on this
virtual machines so we have two types
web Ro and worker roles the web Ro is a
cloud service role that's configured to
run web applications developed on
programming languages Technologies and
majorly they support I internet
information service and they support
asp.net PHP uh Windows communication
foundation and so on on so that's web
roles and these web roles it
automatically deploys and hosts
application through the users IIs
internet information service on the
other hand worker roles are roles that
uh runs applications and service level
tasks which generally do not require IAS
so IAS is actually the differentiating
factor so in worker roles I is not
installed by default the worker roles
are mainly used to perform supporting
background process along with web roles
and do tasks automatically compressing
or uploading the images running scripts
and U or doing some changes in the
database getting new messages from the Q
and processing and lot more you know the
work the applications are the work that
does not require IAS that's what this
worker role does again the main
difference between the web rooll and the
worker Ro is that the web Ro
automatically deploys and hosts your
application through is whereas the
worker role does not use IAS and runs
our application as Standalone this is
another classic question what is azure
service fabric so Azure service fabric
is actually a distributed system
platform that makes it easy to pack
deploy and manage a scalable and
reliable microservices and containers
now service fabric also addresses some
of the significant challenges in
developing and managing Cloud native
applications and the problem that IT
addresses and fixes is now developers
and administrators can avoid complex
infrastructure problems and focus on
implementing Mission critical and
demanding workloads that can be scaled
and that can be managed through the
console or from the single place in
short service fabric provides a platform
that makes the process of developing
microservices and managing application
life cycle lot easier and the advantages
of service fabric is that now we can
produce application with faster time to
Market because all the worry about the
infrastructure is taken away from us we
don't have to design an infrastructure
all that we need to worry about is
simply the application and the
application life cycle again the
advantage is it supports uh Windows it
supports Linux not only that it supports
servers on premises and in the cloud
with service fabric we can scale up our
environment to even thousand machines in
just a single command or if there is a
immediate need for th000 machines I can
immediately scale them up 2,000 machines
that's possible with service fabric now
let's look at this question you can
expect this question if the customer is
running hybrid environment meaning
having some of the applications in on
premises and running some of the
applications from the cloud and for some
reason when classifying the application
that goes to the cloud and that stays on
premises they have decided to keep the
database inhouse so in that environment
a lot of customers do that so in that
environment this is a classic and a have
your based question a client wants the
front end of their application to be
hosted on Azure in the cloud and wants
the database to be hosted in on premises
for security reasons or to have full
control on their databases how do we go
about suggesting a solution for this
customer the ideal solution in this
scenario is to use um the vnet based
point to site VPN uh solution so all the
frontend applications will be in the
cloud and they'll be hosted in a v-net
and from the wiet they'll be connecting
to the database through an point to site
VPN so the traffic and the writings and
the reads are not coming through the
internet but through a point to site VPN
link that's connecting the Azure vet and
the on premises environment and this uh
model or this approach or this solution
is best suited for scenarios where there
are only a limited number of resource
that needs to be connected between on
premises and the cloud this is a very
common question what's Azure traffic
manager of course we no more running
applications on a single server we no
more running applications on or or from
a single environment the same
application is being run from multiple
environments within Azure and it can be
running from Azure and on premise as
well so multiple environments between
Azure and on premises and a lot of
customers have such environment and if
you're facing an interview with such
customer this could be an ideal question
what is azure traffic manager now the
Azure traffic manager is a dns-based
traffic load balancer that actually
enables us to distribute traffic between
Services across Azure Global regions and
by doing this it provides a good
availability and a good responsiveness
to the application and this traffic
manager it uses DNS to direct client
requests to the most appropriate service
endpoint based on the traffic routing
logic and the health of the end points
that it maintains so in short this
traffic manager is a load balancer that
enables users to provide High
availability and responsiveness by
Distributing traffic in an optimal
manner across the Azure when we run the
same application in different regions so
some of the advantages or some of the
use cases of using Azure traffic manager
is it provides multiple automatic
failover options it also helps with
reduced downtime it also helps with
distribution of user traffic across
multiple locations so one location is
not overloaded and then it helps with
users knowing from where our customers
are getting connected from that's
another big use case with Azure traffic
manager let's look at this question
right this is an ideal question now
there are group of servers connected
together within an virtual uh Network
and now we need to move them or create a
separation between them how do you go
about achieving it so the question goes
like this you need to isolate Network
traffic among VMS in a subnet which is
part of a virtual network with little
downtime and impact on the user so
that's the given scenario and the best
way we can uh do it is create a new
virtual Network and move all the VMS in
that subnet to the new virtual Network
now this feature is not possible with a
lot of other cloud service providers
like AWS and a lot of other providers
now in those environments we might need
to to shut down we might need to stop
the VM create a new VM based on the
image and it's an Hefty process but here
in Azure I can simply move the VMS from
one subnet to another virtual Network
without needing for any additional
security like the network security group
I can simply isolate them if I need to
by creating a simple new virtual Network
and moving the servers to the new
virtual Network look at this one this is
another common question with with
respect to Azure what is public private
and hybrid Cloud so this is really to
test how well have you understood the
different Cloud offerings in the market
public private and hybrid or at least
the three basic offerings in the market
public private and hybrid Cloud now the
public cloud is the most common way of
deploying Cloud uh Computing
applications and uh it has resources
like uh servers storage and are owned
and operated by third party cloud
service providers like Microsoft Azure
Microsoft Azure is a very good example
of public Cloud so here every component
that the user is using is running only
on Azure that's public Cloud right let
me talk to you about some of the
advantages of public Cloud some of the
advantages is lowcost because there's no
need to purchase Hardware or software
and we pay only for the services that we
use in public cloud and there's
literally no maintenance because uh the
service provider maintains the
environment for us and uh with public
Cloud we have nearly unlimited
scalability meaning we can get resources
on demand and can meet our business
requirements on demand and the public
clouds are very highly uh reliable
because uh they have a vast network of
servers and they ensure that uh our
application does not fail so there are
some advantages of public Cloud let's
talk about private Cloud now private
Cloud uh consists of computer resources
used extensively by one business or one
organization now this private Cloud can
be physically located at our
organizations on-site data center or it
can be hosted by a third party service
provider whichever the case the private
cloud services and infrastructure are
always maintained on a private Network
and they maintained on hardware and
software that are dedicated solely for
one organization or solely for your
organization so in short private cloud
in Azure is azure Services being run
within an on premises data center or on
premises Data Center used by the user to
host systems or applications and some of
the advantages some of the advantages is
it gives more security resources are not
shared with others so higher level of
control and security over our resource
and application is possible and then we
have hybrid Cloud now hybrid cloud is
the best of both worlds so it combines
the features of both public and private
cloud and some of the user components
are being run on Azure and others within
on premises data center so they kind of
share the resources in other words they
kind of share the application half of
the application would be running in on
premises and half of them would be uh in
the cloud and they will be working in
harmony to support the application and
the business need so that's hybrid Cloud
this is one another good example
question that wants to test how well you
pick services or how well have you
understood aure your products and
services and are picking the right
service for the need so the question
would go like this what kind of storage
is best suited to handle unstructured
data there are a lot of storage options
available and the requirement here is
what or which one would you choose for
unstructured data the answer for that
question is blob storage because blob
storage is designed to support
unstructured data it works in this way
it places the data into different tiers
based on how often they are accessed
different tier mean means different
performance different performance means
different cost associated with it so a
lot of add-on advantages will we get
when we use blob storage for
unstructured data in addition to it any
type of unstructured data can be stored
in Blob storage this is not true with
couple of other storage options that we
have in Azure only with blob storage we
can uh store any type of unstructured
data and the data Integrity is
maintained every time an object is
changed in the blob storage and the best
part is the blob storage helps increase
applications performance and reduces the
bandwidth consumption and reduces the
bandwidth consumption for that
application so they are the benefits
that we get for blob storage and blob
storage are the ones that are well
suited for unstructured data and that's
what your answer should be it's really
an five-step process and if you have
worked and if we have done some Labs
some basic Labs with Azure you can
easily answer this question so it's a
five-step process first step is to log
into the Azure the second one is to
create an uh resource resource or a
resource manager and within the resource
manager you would be selecting the
resource and then pick the uh operating
system do you want windows or Linux and
within Windows what's the flavor you
want or within Linux what's the flavor
you want so decide on it and then U
entering the relevant information
relevant information like the U uh name
of the uh instance or the VM that we're
going to launch and the password uh the
URL that goes with it and couple of
other relevant information that goes
gets itself attached with the VM and
then select the size of the virtual
machine different size different uh uh
types available for the kind of
application and for the intensity of the
application that will be running on top
of it so select the virtual select the
size of the virtual machine review
everything whether they're good or not
if there are any changes required go
back and edit them and then come back
and launch and your VM is there for you
to start working within like 3 or 4
minutes not even 5 minutes within 3 or 4
minutes it gets ready and you can start
working on it so it's a quick and it's a
fstep process and you should be able to
answer it easily if you have done a few
labs in Azure let's now look at some
scenario based question you've been
posted with a scenario so we thought
through it and we picked some common
scenario based question that are being
asked in interview and I thought we'll
present it for you with answers with
explanation so you can get benefited
through it so let's look at this
question you're asked to make sure your
virtual machines are able to communicate
securely with each other to ensure
security or to have good amount of
security what would you do and the
correct and the best answer for this
would be using virtual Network in Azure
which enables us to communicate with the
internet securely which enables us to
communicate with the on premises data
center in a secure fashion so the
advantage of of using virtual network is
users can create their own private
Network users can pick their own private
IP ranges users can create their own
subnet users can create their own
routing between those two subnets a lot
more goes into that virtual Network so
it it's very customizable and the users
are provided with an isolated and highly
secure environment for applications it's
completely isolated from other customers
it's completely isolated from other
applications that are running in other
virtual Network that we own So within
our account we can have multiple virtual
networks and one application running on
a virtual machine is completely isolated
from other applications running on other
virtual machines and uh of course all
traffic stays within the Azure Network
Azure virtual machine or within the
Azure Network depending on how you set
up the routing if you have set up
routing to go or reach the Internet it's
going to go otherwise it's going to stay
within Azure if you have set up routing
to reach on premises then it's going to
go and reach on premises otherwise it's
not going to go and reach on premises
it's going to stay within the Azure and
it also allows users to design their own
network like we already discussed
picking up IPS picking routing you know
picking subnets you know how many
servers should be present in that
particular subnet or how many servers
should that subnet accommodate the size
of the subnet the IP ranges the nting
the masking of ips creating of VPN all
that's possible with the virtual Network
so it really allows users to design
their own network and using virtual
machine is how we secure applications in
the cloud let's look at this other
scenario how do you ensure that every
time a user logs in they are not asked
to re-enter the password as part of
authentication so you really don't want
your users to re-enter the password
every time they log in to a different
application well all the applications
have their authentication mechanism in
place all of them wants to authenticate
the user before the login ensuring the
user does not log in every time does not
mean that wiping away all the
authentication and authorization that's
present in that application you still
need that in place but how do you make
the user hasslefree so they're not asked
to re-enter the password or the same
password again and again let's look at
the options available the first one is
to enable Microsoft account
Authentication ation well it's not going
to fix because with that the user will
still need to re-enter the username and
password a deploy express route it's not
going to fix either because express
route is a network level service that
connects on premises to the cloud so
that has got nothing to do with
prompting or not prompting for password
and then we have a setup VPN between on
premises Data Center and Azure set up ad
domain controller in VM and Implement
integrated windows authentication well
uh you can use the same username and
password for on premises and the cloud
but this setup the the VPN and the ad
controller setup it's not going to stop
you asking for repeative passwords so
this is all about U using the same
password in on premises and in the cloud
and this has got nothing to do with the
U not prompting the user to re-enter the
password all right so that's same
password is different from not prompting
the user to re-enter the password they
are two different scenarios so uh that
is also out of the equation and the last
one is configure ad sync to use single
sign on that's the right one so when we
configure the ad to use uh single sign
on then uh it's going it's not going to
ask for the username and password every
time we access an application because we
have logged in and that login is going
to stay active for like 24 hours or so
depending on how you configure it and
within that time you can access a lot of
other applications and it's not going to
ask for the username and password
because you already have a single signed
on and you have signed in using the
right credentials let's look at this one
you need to ensure that virtual machines
remain available while migrating to
Azure what would be the appropriate
service to use right let's look at the
options traffic manager traffic manager
is um is literally and DNS service and
then let's look at the other one update
domains it again has has to do with
traffic manager updating the URL so the
traffic manager gets updated and then
starts sending request to that
particular uh URL it's going to take
some downtime because when we update the
URL they will have to be populated to
all different places and it takes time
so within that time any user trying to
access it's going to fail and then we
have express route and cloud services
express route could be the in fact it's
the right answer because express route
it's an extension of for on premis and
Cloud environment and in this question
it really comes out from a customer
who's having an hybrid environment so
they have applications running in on
premises they have applications running
in the cloud and they want to have a way
to migrate applications from on premises
to the cloud in other words kind of do a
cutover between on premises and the
cloud and this express route is a
service that connects between on
premises and the cloud uh so when you do
the cut over the traffic is now sent to
the cloud instead of being handled in on
premises in fact the services and the
application is getting down are getting
shut down in on premises so the request
will come in the same pattern instead of
they being handled in on premises they
are now routed to the cloud using
express route and the API calls get
addressed or the the queries gets
answered uh in the cloud through the
express route service look at this
question you are an administrator for a
website called Web game and you required
to validate and deploy changes made to
your website by your development team
with minimum downtime so the real
question is how do you validate the
deployment changes that's made by the
development team let's look at the
options create a new linked resource
create a staging environment for the
site enable remote debugging on the
website and then create a new website
well why would you want to create a new
website just to validate the changes and
doing a remote debugging is not going to
help because debugging only captures
logs of the changes happening it does
not do anything with validating the
changes create a staging environment
could be or is the right answer because
when we have staging environments
anything that we run on production can
be run on staging environment and any
failures that would happen in production
if we simply run it in production can be
captured when we run the application in
the staging environment so that way
staging environment is a very helpful
and useful service and that way I can
catch U any errors in other words I can
validate the changes that were done by
my development team uh before I move it
to production and that reduces the
downtime in the production environment
look at this one last question that we
have for you it's um a standard tier
application is used across the world and
uses Azure website standard tier it uses
large amount of image files so you can
get it this could be an e-commerce
website which has a lot of pictures in
it and this is causing the application
to load slow how can we handle this
situation let's look at the options
given config a blob storage with custom
domain well this application has
pictures but the pictures only the
pictures is not all that the application
has all right so configuring blob
storage might not help this could be an
very interactive website and that can't
be run from blob storage let's look at
the other options configure Azure
website autoscaling to increase
instances at high loads now it's the
picture that's causing issues for the
website it's not the CPU or it's not the
memory unavailable memory not enough
that's causing the application to be
slow so we need to identify what's
causing the application to be slow so
it's not the CPU it's not the memory so
configure Azure for Autos scaling is not
going to help and then what are the
other options let's see configure Azure
CDN to cash all responses from the
application's web endpoint CDN could be
the right answer but but look at that it
says uh CDN to cach all responses from
the applications web endpoint CDN is not
designed for that though it can do it
that's not the best way to use CDN to
capture all responses from the
application's web endpoint the proper
design for CDN would be to Cache the
frequently used ones in other words
cache the static content which are
photos videos logos and pictures and lot
more static content that never changes
let's look at the last option configure
Azure CDN to cach site images and
content stored in Azure blob storage
absolutely correct so here we will have
to redesign the application uh to store
the pictures high quality lazy loading
or slow loading pictures because of the
high quality and the bigger size so
store them in CDN and then the content
let it be stored in Azure blob storage
that's the right way of Designing the
application and if we do it this
application is is going to run faster or
the application is going to respond
faster to the users as we wrap up this
Azure full course we hope you have found
it informative and helpful you now have
a solid understanding of azure's cloud
capabilities keep in mind that learning
is ongoing and Azure is always evolving
we encourage you to keep exploring and
using what you have learned in your work
of projects whether you are starting
something or improving your career Azure
is here to support you thanks for join
joing us on this is your journey staying
ahead in your career requires continuous
learning and upscaling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
[Music]
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here